it wasn't just a one-on-one it could be
steve against the team going we need
glass instead of plastic on the front
face of the iphone and we're going to do
this
and we're like god
you know and so we did it
and he pushed us because he didn't know
all the details but he could see in our
minds that we're like
yeah we could probably yeah we could
probably but man it's really putting us
in risk and we we laid out the risks for
him and he's like i'm willing to take
those risks
the following is a conversation with
tony fidel engineer and designer
co-creator of the ipod the iphone and
the nest thermostat
and he's the author of the new book
build
an unorthodox guide to making things
worth making
more than almost any human ever
he knows what it takes to create
technology ideas designs
products and companies that
revolutionize life for huge numbers of
people in the world
so it truly is an honor and pleasure to
sit down with tony for a time and look
back at one heck of an amazing life
this is the lex treatment podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now
dear friends
here's tony
fidel
when did you first fall in love with
computers
or let's say computer engineering and
design i first fell in love
with
computers and programming was it a
summer school class
in fifth grade
in gross point farms michigan
it was a simple basic programming class
but the basic programming class was not
like you might think it was
it was bubble cards so literally it was
you know
uh the cards the stack of cards and you
would
use a number two pencil and you would
put in your program line by line and
you'd have to make sure it was perfectly
stacked and no errors and what have you
and you'd take that set of cards and
you'd put it on this reader and it was
and it would go off to an ibm
microcomputer somewhere in the
back then the cloud
and then
you would sit on a texas instruments
paper terminal
and it would just
literally i was just i could write
things and it would i could program this
machine to do stuff and it was you know
it was nowhere near sex there was no
graphics right oregon trail was all in
text
right the cards were so cumbersome that
if you got one thing wrong or out of
order it
or a disaster or you dropped one card it
would all fall apart
so um
just doing that you know print f or was
it i can't even remember what there was
it was uh you know
what the what the basic commands were
but also when you say basic you mean
basic programming programming language
okay basic programming you're you're
writing basic programming language
on paper on paper and you're calling it
programming though it's called
programming yeah you're programming this
computer and you know in a remote
location and it came back so it was
truly cloud computing in a way so it was
really terminal based computing uh and
the input and the program are separate
so the input to the program or they
could go together like um or is there no
input to the program it just runs and it
gives you output yeah you it goes in and
says it says ready and then you can say
run yeah and then it would run but to
program it it you didn't type it because
it was a printer terminal you would make
the stack of cards and that would get it
into the the computer's memory okay so
where was the magic
the magic was that you could
create you had a language and you could
create what you wanted to create right
you could create a world or or what have
you and have this interaction and you
could
compute things you could you know do
numbers you could i was playing oregon
trail
right
so you're less like you can play video
games
well video that's right you could play
text games and then imagine them in your
brain right
oregon trail there's a this meme i saw
recently if you want to feel bad about
yourself as a programmer
realize that one person wrote railroad
tycoon i think that's the name of the
game it's this cool little builder game
one person wrote it in assembly
[Laughter]
so for like from scratch and for people
who don't know it kind of looks like a
sim city type game it's a city builder
but obviously centered on railroads and
there's a nice graphics the three
dimension all that kind of stuff all the
things
all the rich colorful things you would
imagine for for a three-dimensional
video game all written in assembly
meaning the lowest level code next to
binary yeah which is uh fascinating and
that's the
you had to notice the magic
at that low level at that time you
didn't have all the graphics you didn't
have all the
like apis and all the sample codes no
stack overflow no internet none of that
you just had you had to know registers
you know had to know the op codes and
you had to imagine the world in your
brain of the memory structures and
everything else there's no visualization
you visualized it all yourself right and
so that was magic but then the next part
of the magic of where i got hooked even
further was like i'm doing these little
things
and then electronic arts came out for
the apple ii so i got an apple ii and
electronic arts came out and i was
programming and doing basic and making
my own games
but then there were two games that
really blew my mind one was pinball
construction set and the other one was
music construction set and these were
both places where i could create pinball
games and i could create musical scores
because i loved music and i could then
play them right and so when you had that
you were like oh there's something very
different
so i could create myself
but then there was others that create
tools so you could create at a visual
level and then you would read the back
stories because electronics arts back in
the day it was one programmer who would
program those things you know each of
those things and you could read their
backstories it was literally like like a
musician or someone else like you could
read rick rubin's like here's a thing
they tell you all that stuff and there
was one guy
who wrote music construction set he
wrote it all in assembly and he was 16
years old wow
and i went and i was probably 12 or 13
at the time
and i went oh my
if he was able to do this and had
published right and this amazing tool
was created i'm like what can i do and
so then it it it just kept building off
of that but really it was those seminal
things first the introduction and then
the you know the power through
programming and turning these things
into what you wanted to turn it into and
you didn't have to be
40 50 years old and have you know phds
and then i was like okay
this is really cool i wish we did that
with programmers where we treated them
like artists we would know the backstory
these days today or not just programmers
engineers engineers designers yeah like
all the things about a product that i
think we love are the little details and
there's probably a human being behind
each of those details
that had their little inkling of genius
that they put in and i wish we knew
those stories that's always sad to me
when i because i obviously i love
engineering and i interact with
companies and they you know autonomous
vehicles something i'm really interested
about and i see
that companies generally and will
probably talk about this but they they
seem to want to hide their engineers
like engineers hold the secrets
like the great secret we did not speak
of the greatest great
but then the result of that is you don't
you don't get to hear their stories
the
the passion that is there behind the
engineers
like and also the genius the little
there's a difference between the stuff
that's patented like the kernel of the
idea right and and the beautiful sort of
side effects of the idea and i wish
companies revealed the beautiful side
effects a little bit more
but yeah so sorry for the distraction so
what uh you mentioned apple ii what was
the first computer you fell in love with
like the
the product the thing before you that
was a personal computer
it was the apple ii
so the apple ii was something i was just
lusting over you know it was
i think it was at the time it was the um
you know the person of the year maybe it
was that year i don't remember what but
well apple ii was the person the person
of the year yeah for my time magazine
back and i don't remember when but it
was around that same time i was so young
but i had there was the apple too and i
didn't know what it was but i knew about
tools because my grandfather taught me
all about tools and
creating things right
and i saw this thing and and i had that
you know that that ibm experience that
terminal experience and i'm like oh i
could have that at home right and so i
need to have that at home and the only
thing that was really talked about in in
our circles was the apple ii and i was
just like that's it
so
i went jumped up and down it was very
expensive i have to have this my parents
like what you know it was twenty five
twenty five hundred dollars back then
yeah in the 1981 was like crazy right
so i was like i'm gonna make as much
money as i can this summer and my
grandfather said because he he helped me
learn all about tools and build things
together
i will match whatever you make so you
can get this computer so i worked very
very hard as a caddy golf caddy catting
actually for the you know that the
families in you know at the country
clubs in the in the town um where we
lived
and uh did whatever i could and that end
of that summer we got my apple too and
now you couldn't tear it away from me it
was my my friend it was everything from
a product perspective what do you
remember that was brilliant
um
the design choices the ideas behind it
or is it just that it exists or the very
idea of a personal computer is the
brilliant design choice
yeah it was that i could actually have
this kind of tool in my house and i
could use it anytime i wanted i could
program it anyways there was no you know
there was no internet connection there
was no it was all just you you either
loaded software that you got from
someone right
um or you created yourself and then
there was a whole other thing which was
started happening which we were doing
and this was kind of like mp3s and stuff
we were sharing software right so you
built this community of sharing stuff
you would you you would go in pirate
that was what called pirate all this
software you'd never use it all but it
was just that fun thing of like i'm
gonna get all this other stuff and then
tear it apart and do disassembly on it
and see behind the scenes so you really
had a sense that this was your world and
you owned it right and you could like
literally go into every register we
didn't have all those security layers
like we do not like you could really
touch bits and you could poke bits and
you can make this light turn on and you
know and the geek assignment just lit up
now you can there's
it's so abstract you know people don't
even understand like usually you know
some programs don't even understand
memory they just think it's unlimited
right yeah and security it's like now
there's all this security you should
have but it's like the adults all showed
up to
to the party and now you can't have all
the fun right it's like no no you know
this was the thing where if you if if
the power went out yeah you lost your
whole program you might have worked a
whole day on it and if you didn't press
save at every other line and you were
saved save save and it would like grow
the word the disk drive or the tape
drive
like
every single step was contemplated
because if you didn't you lost maybe a
ton of work
so a lot of the magic was in the
software the fact that you could have
software the fact that you could share
software
the
in the community around the software it
wasn't necessarily the hardware well
that was the first step the second step
around the hardware was i got things
like the mockingboard which the
mockingboard paired with the music
instruction set you could now generate
all kinds of tones and notes and it was
a synthesizer in the apple ii so you
would plug in this card and go oh my god
look at this and it would you know you
could start generating cool sounds
you're like like it was a moog you know
like a moog in a way early moog
what year are we talking about this is
82 i think
81.82 and i bet you can make all the
kind of synthetic sounds that are very
cool in the 80s yeah yeah eight bit you
know chip tunes right
and then um and then you know when you
wanted to add a joystick you had to pull
a chip out and you had to like plug in a
dip socket to put in a joystick and and
then i was like oh and then i had to get
more memory how do we do that and i
wanted to speed up products so so then
that turned into a company actually
from that but it was in a hardware
software at that um but it was all about
you know modifying this thing in every
way first was software and then you
started gaining confidence and then i
got a little bit more money and stuff
and then you could get into the hardware
and you know wire things and then the
apple ii came with all the schematics
right so in the back
in the early apple twos you could open
up and all the schematics were there
you purchased the apple ii and the
schematics come with it yeah it came
with it
that's an interesting choice that's an
interesting choice from from a company
perspective right so it's like a real
maker kind of thing right
i wonder what they
so that was intentional like this is
absolutely intentional this is the work
this is for the cutting edge folks too
or especially if it was only the cutting
edge it was geeks for geeks yeah so we
were like oh how did they make it and
then we got to learn through that apple
one did the same thing right it just
apple ii became more packaged up and had
you know a little bit better software
right came with basic and then you know
so so it was really it was it was what
we might think of as a raspberry pi
today or something like that but not
with so much software it was literally
and all the chips were out there so you
could inspect the buses and the right
because everything was just broken out
so i guess
that's the idea behind
stable big projects in open source like
on github
that you have the schematics there
and it's it's kind of a product but i
wonder why more companies don't do that
kind of thing like we're going to
release this
to a small set of people
self-selected
perhaps
that are kind of the makers the cutting
edge folks the builders
the at-home engineers like in some way
what uh tesla is doing with the beta for
the
full self driving it's kind of like that
it's like selecting a group of people
but that has to do more with you
how safe of a driver you are versus how
much of a tank carrier you are because
you don't get to tinker i wonder is that
is that a crazy idea to to do for really
cutting-edge technologies especially
you're interested in
like hardware stuff is that is that
crazy why don't more companies do that
kind of thing you think
i i think back then it was about a
community and serving that community of
builders and now this is about people
who want to take get the experience and
want it really simple and easy and
they're like and so it is there's the
the audience or they believe the
audience is small who would value those
other things that we're just talking
about but if we look at things like
raspberry pi and all of these other
little boards right
there's a whole world more than any that
i've seen like it's amazing what you can
do now with these little kits um and and
and the software that's created and and
and so there's a whole nother i think
another batch of makers and builders
that are coming up through the ranks and
if you we look at youtube channels and
stuff right they take these little
boards they hack them then they print
out
you know parts on their 3d printer
assemble them and they create robots and
what have you so i think it's happening
um it's just not as you know as it's
just not as i guess
raw as it used to be
um but it's there and it's really
expanding around the world and that's
really nice to see because you know it's
a whole new generation uh who can who
are empowered i think there's a
semi-dormant
genius amongst millions so like
raspberry pi is revealing that a little
bit it's probably
i wouldn't be surprised if it's several
million raspberry pies that have been
sold i think it should
and it's kind of this quiet
storm
of genius brewing of engineers we don't
get to hear it because they're not
organized i mean we get to hear their
inklings here and there like i said
youtube there's little communities that
are local and so on but if they were
organized
[Laughter]
if a leader would emerge no okay so when
did you first start to dream about
building your own things
designing your own products
designing your own systems
and software and hardware well in high
school
there was a company that
um
a friend of mine founded and i was the
second employee was called quality
computers
and it was a male
mail order mail order because there's no
e-commerce then there was no internet
again yeah you either mailed in your
little coupon and you said this is what
i wanted to order or you wrote in to get
a catalog and deliver to you you know
turn around time and this stuff was like
from the time you wanted the time you
bought it was maybe eight to twelve
weeks that was just the normal way of
getting things
so quality computers was a mail order
for apple ii and it was software
and and all kinds of accessories so
hardware accessories so hardware plug-in
cards joysticks all this stuff
and what um we noticed was um there were
accelerator cutters or memory cards
and to be able to use those cards
you had to actually go and change the
software you used to access this new
memory so you literally have to go and
you took the program that you had let's
say was appleworks which was like an
early microsoft office or something like
that
and you had to literally change the code
and you would install all these patches
to then take advantage of the hardware
so what we started creating was software
on top of it to do the automatic
installation of all of these patches
so we made it much easier to take new
hardware and then and and the existing
software you have and expand it into
this new world so it was creating tools
and that really great customer support
and we we started getting a lot of
orders because we had the software make
it easier to install to give them the
superpower
and at the same time um
uh you know they they would be able to
change their software and and have a new
world that wasn't existing from the
companies that were creating the initial
products
and so it was more of that and then that
happened with uh
hard drives so i wrote a hard drive
optimizer for the apple ii to like read
because you could get really fragmented
so i wrote that piece of software and we
sold that through the company along with
the hard drives that we sold from third
parties so
that all happened in 12th grade uh
freshman year of college
you're a hard drive optimizer in 12th
grade
you know yeah between 12th and freshman
year what programming language do you
remember is it assemblies it was there
were certain inner loops were assembly
and other loops actually there were
really early pascal no c um um see
see uh compilers what was the motivation
behind these is it
to make people's lives easier is it to
create a thing experience that is
simpler and simpler and simpler
thereby more accessible to large your
number of people like what or did you
just like like to tinker no no it was
two things really because one we wanted
to sell more hardware and software right
so it was like oh make it easier for the
user and then the other thing was
because i was also manning the customer
support line
people would call and go this doesn't
work and i'm like oh i gotta go fix the
hardware and software right or i gotta
fix the software to make the hardware
and the installation process better so
my whole world was out of box experience
from when i was in high school
because i had to man the customer
support line pack the boxes and write
some of the code while we were doing
well joe joe gleason who was the founder
of quality computers he was off doing
the mark the ads placing the ads for the
mail order making sure we were running
the credit cards right yeah
it was two of us and then it turned into
a third and then we hired another person
from high school to like pack boxes so i
could stay on the customer support line
or doing the software right and it was
all in his parents basement yeah right
as you were scaling exponentially
scaling right yeah exactly bootstrapping
so we'll jump around a little bit but
what were the you said you loved music
what were the ideas that gave birth to
the ipod if we jump
forward uh and how far back do those
ideas stretch
you know if you look at the history of
technology
there's
i mean not just the product but the idea
is is truly revolutionary
maybe
its time has come
but just if you look at the arc
of history
instead of music
is so fundamental to who we are as a
humanity right and to be able to put
that in your
pocket make it truly portable is
fascinating in in a way
that's truly portable so it's digital
as opposed to sort of uh like a walkman
or something like that so
what were the ideas that gave birth to
the ipod
you know i've i was in love with music
since i was a kid
just loved music from i think second
grade when i got my first albums and
stuff like that what kind of music are
we talking about so this was um
this was led zeppelin
this was the stones hendricks uh
aerosmith
uh uh
cheap trick sticks ted nugent you know
just the real
you know the real american and so and
british rock and roll right there's a
bunch of people listening right now who
ten who's who who's that zeppelin what
is that
[Laughter]
um it drove my parents crazy yeah yeah
just blasted loud loud just right and
this was second third grade fourth guy i
just i fell in love and then
uh we um
we moved back to detroit
and i loved listening to the radio
station because there was all kinds of
crazy music because you'd have a
amalgam of rock and then funk and r b
and i loved to listen at night so i had
a clock radio
but if i had the clock radio on everyone
like the parents go go to sleep stop
that turn that stuff off so i hacked the
clock radio and put a headphone jack in
it
nice
right so i said oh they're wow
okay
and then and then i could listen to it
all night and no one could hear me right
and i could just sit there and you know
just huddling around the radio groove
out just listening to zeppelin
stairway to heaven
what would you say is the greatest uh
rock classic rock song of all time
greatest classic rock song of all time
well it pops into mine well no you know
what i mean this has to be that's just
really hard dude this is nice
dude this is
a serious journalistic interview
you're not going to back down from these
kinds of questions oh my god no i don't
know challenge yeah it's hard it's hard
to pick but i i to me stairway to heaven
is a safe
fault it's like it's so often considered
to be one of the greatest songs of all
time that you almost don't want to pick
it right exactly but you've returned to
it time and time again and it's like
yeah this is
this is something pretty special
this is a rock opera
of sorts well the rock opera that really
blew me away and still continues to blow
me away is all of dark side of the moon
like that
i love that yeah i love zeppelin i i
can't say which one's better but dark
side of the moon for me was it was a
you know audio experience right the
whole thing from soup to nuts plus all
the synthesizers all of those things
okay so back back to the ipod so that's
you from the early age you loved music
loved it absolutely loved it and you
know always was just around it and
always i just it was always playing you
know
um i
played it so loud that i actually hurt
the earring in my right ear
and i still suffer from that today
um and then no regrets no regrets
whatsoever going to concerts in downtown
detroit and all that crazy stuff so
moving forward um
so i in college i was a dj
so i would dj and hang out and play all
the tunes i love and whatever for the
for the crowd and then i continue to do
that in silicon valley
when when i moved right after school
and so i was be lugging all of these cds
around with me a thousand cds to right
and
and at the same time
um and so those were heavy and at the
same time i was doing the philips nino
and velo those are window ce based
mobile computing products
the nino was the first
device to actually put audible books on
tape so we i worked with audible we met
in a conference and they were like we
don't want to do hardware we just want
to do content i was like well we have
this device let's get it together and we
got audible on that and this was in
96 or seven
first audible books and it you know as i
was oh my god that's audio
well what if we put music on it
right and so i i go and the memory was
very small at the time right there was
almost there was almost no flash it was
all dram when you did audible you
started in dram
right which was okay probably because
uh how much
books do you need is the idea by the way
brilliant i mean just putting books
i know it's probably not the sexiest of
things but putting books
on
on a mobile device is a brilliant step
i i don't know sometimes can't measure
how much human progress occurred because
of an invention like there's the sexy
big products but you never know like
maybe like wikipedia is one of those
things that doesn't get enough
i think credit for the transformational
effects it has it's not seen as the
sexiest of products but maybe it is when
you look at human history
wikipedia
arguably is one of the big things that
that basically
unlocked human knowledge human knowledge
okay and human editing and human you
know just
the human
human nature of building something
together yeah so it's it's fascinating
sometimes you can't measure those things
maybe until many many decades later
anyway sorry so that was that was the
nino that was so that was there and then
there was audible you put books why not
put music music and i'm carrying around
the music for the dj gigs and you're
like wait a second uh two and two
together right like get let's get rid of
this and so and then mp3 show up
the the actual like encoder performance
the format mp3 showed up around
97.98
so mp3 is
is compressed so you can
have uh like the storage is reduced
significantly right so you could go from
a um you know a large full full uh
losses lossless um you know digital
track into something that can be stored
in
four to eight megabytes something like
that for the audio now you know that's a
reduced quality but you could get it
down there and you're like oh
okay and now if we have enough flash or
dram we can put 10 15 what have you all
in in that same memory and it starts to
replicate a cd and then ultimately if
you put it on a hard drive you could
start to put you know thousands of songs
yeah that's that's also another
brilliant invention like people don't
realize i think i think people would be
surprised how big in terms of storage
raw audio is
and the fact that you can compress it
like
uh
i don't know what the compression is but
it's like 10x it's very significant
compression and still it sounds almost
lossless much of the chagrin of neil
young who yeah who does not like that
but even even neil young
even the stuff he talks about is still
tiny files relative to the raw right so
he he wants us to increase it just a
little bit more a little bit more but
it's still that's an invention that's a
thing that unlocks your ability to carry
around a device like nino and listen to
music because without that there's no
way you can carry on a gigantic hard
drive
right exactly and so so then that so it
was mp3s the nino and my you know my my
hatred of carrying around all this heavy
stuff that then spawned you know um
fused and then ultimately you know
became a lot of that the ideas and
things of that nature were
and and my passions were born into then
the ipod you know it was too
apple needed something and i wanted to
fix something and it it all kind of you
know came together at this right right
place right time plus the right
technology came at this it was just like
the stars aligned so how did it come to
life
the details of
the stars aligning but the actual design
the actual engineering of getting a
device to be small
the uh
the storage of the you know the
interface how it looks sure
the storage the details of the software
all that kind of stuff what what are
some interesting memories from that
design process what are some wisdoms you
you can
part okay from that process well
you know how long do you want to go
because i have i can go deep uh so uh
let's go at least 20 hours let's go okay
yeah that's one of those lengthy
documentaries we're gonna turn it into
episodic uh yeah binge [ __ ]
game of thrones so let's just start with
uh you know after i was asked to be a
consultant to put this thing together
so i had already had knowledge of you
know the the space and the technology
and all that stuff but i had to very
quickly
and and a lot of the suppliers because
of what i was doing at fuse trying to
create that thing so
at
at as a contractor i was like okay what
is the first thing you need to do so
so after i showed a you know
different architectures and what three
different products could be
to steve about options for storage
options battery options form factor
options there was three options
and as i was was i told given very good
advice give to the the two options you
really do not like but their options and
give the best option last because steve
will shut you know shoot all those down
and give the
the best option last and then you could
talk about that and so that was the one
um
that had a 1.8 inch hard drive
and a small screen
uh like with the screen you you you know
it uh i am not on the original ipod
classic ipod
and uh and then i had enough of the idea
of the three or three or four different
uh
cpus and processor suppliers and kind of
systems that were out there that i had
gone and found and put together on power
supplies you know uh disk drive
interfaces firewire interface all that
stuff so i put together all of those
those schematics or you know block
diagrams they weren't schematics yet
because it was just me
and coming up with a bill of materials
coming up with what it could look like
what would be the input output how we
could uh
make a better headphone jack
um that was also on there screen
suppliers
tearing apart calculators so got all
calculators and all kinds of electronics
to get the the right size um
different sizes of small lcds
so i got all kinds of different battery
types i got different types of uh you
know in different battery sizes double
a's
aaa's working through all the different
and there was lithium ion nickel metal
hydride so i took all the battery types
i took all of the um memory types
processing types lcd types
and
um
and and connectivity and all that stuff
not wireless but wired
and
laid out these things as lego blocks
so literally i had all of these things
as just and so i i made them so i could
like you know put them together and
figure out what the compact fact form
factor would be oh like how do we shove
them together what's the smallest
possible box you can get so the the
questions without the storage so the
hard drive
batteries double a triple a you're right
screens so screen size and then for that
you're tearing apart calculators
calculators
digital cameras whatever and getting
little things right so so you can make
it physical right if you can make the
intangible tangible like and so i can
say look we can make this and i could i
brought this whole bag of goods and it
was like
right like here's this here's this this
is why double a's won't work and because
it makes it too fat and everything so
just educate everybody through here's
the parts that we can use you should not
sheet a paper it's physical you're
playing in the physical space well i
would go back and forth so
truth be told because there weren't a
good enough graphical tools on on a
on the mac i was using a pc with vizio
and some 3d tools and i was doing 3d
design at the same time i was taking all
these physical parts and going okay what
feels right because you have to go from
you know the details and then the rough
and you go back and forth and you
iterate right and so it was just a lot
of fun and then i ultimately ended up
with a styrofoam model and printouts
that came from vizio that i glued
together and put my grandfather's
fishing weights in because i also
modeled the weights
right so i i said oh this is this many
ounces this is this many ounces in grams
and then i went and got all that and
made the weighted these styrofoam models
to then match that so when you picked it
up it felt more or less form factor
right and it also you felt
how much you know was it going to be
dense enough is it going to feel solid
and rigid in your hand
right why does need to feel rigid
because it has to feel substantial it
has to feel like i have like a like a
bar of gold in my hand right you know
maybe you know this when you open and
close a car door you know that thunk and
you go bam and you go that feels solid
that feels real and then you get this
tinny car that's like ding and you're
like does this feel safe does this feel
like a value and so you when you have a
device like that and you you want to
make sure that there's not too much air
in it that
you've distributed the density of the
masses in the right way so it feels like
it's the right thing so you have to
model battery life costs
uh you know
mass
sizes of different things and then you
have to also think about what the ui is
going to look like right so you have all
of these constraints your work variables
you're working with and you have to kind
of you know you can't get the perfect of
everything what's the best you know
local maximum of all of these components
that come together to provide an
experience local max it's always
trade-offs what about buttons
buttons well there was also the buttons
too right oh by the way a lot of these
battles fought inside your mind or is it
with other people is it uh is it with
steve is it lower like what this was all
independent this was me before being
able to present to see because i had to
feel really confident
that
if i was going to put this in front of
him that it could be made right so i had
to convince myself and go work through
all the details through the like the
very very rough mechanical design
electrical design software things
because i didn't want to present
something that was going to be fictional
right my credibility would be like
trashed
right so you mentioned convince yourself
you're painting this beautiful picture
of of a driven
engineer designer
uh futurist
how much doubt were you played by
through that like this this is even
doable because it's not obvious that
this is even doable
like to do this at scale to do this kind
of thing to make it sexy
to uh
[Music]
shovel
the screen the batteries the storage
to make the interface the hardware and
the software interface work all of that
i mean i don't know i would be
overwhelmed by the doubt of that because
so many things have to work plus the
supply chain like at that point i wasn't
getting into any of those details or
anything you know there's there's the
basic stuff that you have to put
together and then you have to you know
through my learnings at general magic
and my learnings at philips and
delivering you know multiple you know
large-scale programs in manufacturing
you kind of get a rule of thumb and you
know what to focus on at the beginning
and what not to worry about over time
like when i was early in my career i
worried about everything on the
engineering details so much so that you
know i would be a nervous wreck sooner
or later you learn how to filter out and
figure out what to prioritize and so 10
years later you know i was able to much
do a much better job of filtering out
the things of like we'll get to that in
you know in weeks to come but right now
we got to like solve you know the very
important things which is is could this
actually be something real and that you
could deliver you know enough battery
life right enough of an interface um of
the right cost
right in the right right uh right price
point so you already you were sitting on
on a track record of successes and
failures in your own mind where you had
sort of already a confidence a calm a
calmness
uh but still
was there a doubt that you can get this
done always
always how hard is it to achieve a sort
of a confidence
to a level where you could present it to
steve and actually believe that this is
doable
like what what do you remember one yeah
that moment yeah i think it was after i
triple checked i couldn't i couldn't
bring anyone in
right i couldn't let anyone in on this
so it was just me are they going to
trample on it that kind of thing why no
no because i couldn't bring any what i
mean bring anyone in on this one it was
a highly confidential program inside of
apple there was like four people who
knew about it right
and so i couldn't bring anyone from
apple because i was a contractor i
couldn't bring anyone else from the
outside world i'm working for apple and
i'm under this
crazy nda right in this contract so it
was just
it was so i'm i'm
i'm doing this oh and at the same time
i'm also buying every competitive
product mp3 player and tearing them all
apart yeah right tore them all apart and
looking at them and trying to learn from
those as well so it was all of this
stuff in six weeks so i didn't sleep
right yeah yeah but i i was like because
i was trying to make this from i was i
was envisioning this since the nino
right and i was like oh my god right
but there was another doubt that i had
and it wasn't just could you make the
product but could actu apple actually
have
the um
the balls to make it because apple was
not the same company
that you know it today in 2001
really it was cautious conservative
careful
it was barely break even it was a four
or five billion dollar company oh so the
guts required there is not necessarily
in the innovation it's like this is
going to cost a lot of money and we're
going to potentially lose all of it
because it'll be
a flop
well there's not just that but there was
only the mac
yeah and the mac wasn't doing very well
yeah
there was less it was about a one
percent only in the us market share for
the mac
right
the company was in debt
bill gates had to give him a loan
right michael dell at the time was
saying shut down the company and give
the money back to the shareholders
so
this is not the company that you know
that people oh my god the iphone came
out it's a very different level of
confidence and financial
situation that the company was in versus
the ipod so given that what was the
conversation when you finally presented
to steve
what was that conversation like
the conversation was
well we went we went through it the
presentation and all all that stuff
happened and he he was just like and you
know he never he would flip through it
real quick throw the presentation aside
and said okay let's talk about this
right and so we went through it all
and um
one was a big conversation about sony
and sony was the number one in all audio
categories home portable what
in the world okay
i had been already gone through 10 years
of failure and i was like wait a second
how are we going to compete with sony
and i was always worried that sony was
going to come out with whatever it was
they were going to come out with their
mp3 player and that was it game over
right
and so i was like
steve
and and this is why it took me
four weeks to finally sign on to join
apple after he greenlighted the ipod
program in that meeting was because
i had built other things in the past at
philips the nino and velo but they
didn't know how to sell it or market it
they didn't know how to retail it
right so i was like we could build this
and i was like steve i'm pretty sure i
can build this i've done this before
but how are we going to sell it
you have all your marketing dollars on
the mac
and he looked at me and he goes you
build this
with you know a team and our team and
apple open business and me right
and
i dedicate that we will make sure that
at least two quarters of all marketing
dollars will only go to this product and
nothing else
wow
right that was mac was the lifeblood of
all revenue of the company so steve saw
something special here
exactly
and he said i'm going to commit all the
marketing dollars if you can deliver the
experience that we're all talking about
if we can do that and that was jeff
robin as well because i ipod would have
never happened without itunes you know
people don't understand that was a
bundle you couldn't do one without the
other and vice versa so jeff and i were
you know if jeff and you can present and
bring that um
bring that experience to life
i will put all the marketing dollars
behind it when did the marriage of ipod
and itunes
sort of
uh
what was that
a birth of ideas that made up itunes
itunes existed before the ipod
okay
and so jeff robin had his company oh man
i can't remember her name but it was
bought he was making a mp3 player app
for the mac
steve saw it because there was mp3
player apps like winamp and other things
that were on the pc real player and
steve saw that going on and saw that
jeff and his small team had this this i
can't remember sound something
anyways he bought that and that became
the basis of itunes and then jeff ran
all of itunes
and so what happened specifically there
was they were starting to hook up to all
these third-party mp3 players
because there's a lot of korean
the mp man like walkman but empty man
all these
and they were trying to hook them up and
they were like these are horrible
experiences and through that and they
said
itunes was something that was going to
help grow the mac base because we were
trying to get more and people
on the mac so this program would be a
great new thing you could add to the mac
and there was also internet connectivity
at the time for the imac
and so they did that and then they're
trying to do these these hookups they
weren't going well and that's when they
said we need to build our own or steve
said we need to build our own since
these are such horrible experiences
people don't want to just burn cds from
itunes we need to get that music on the
go but in an apple fashion that's when i
was called
to come in to do that the ipod thing
after the six weeks then he already
envisioned i'm sure he had envisioned
because they were trying to do this
thing okay now that's it
itunes what you know it wasn't called
ipod yet you know what would become the
ipod that is going to be the thing that
then propels apple into this new thing
because you bring all these music lovers
in that are going to need their
their
next generation or sony walkman
version 2.0
so when you look at again
apologies to linger on ipod but it's one
of the great inventions
uh in in tech history
what wisdom do you draw from that whole
process about
spotting an idea this is something you
talk about in your book
build
how do you know that an idea is
brilliant at which stage when did you
know it was a good idea
[Laughter]
and maybe is there like some
phase shifts
first your complete doubt then maybe hmm
and then maybe it becomes more than
and becomes like a little more
confidence that kind of stuff and also
wisdom about who to talk to
right uh so they don't trample the idea
in the early stages that kind of stuff
and your thoughts about this we could go
on again how long do you want to go
this is a netflix series i told you
multi-season
so a lot of lessons learned over those
years of failure and success but
the first thing it starts with
um there's a whole chapter called great
ideas chase you and so it kind of goes
into in build and you can go and it goes
through kind of chapter and verse about
all of those how nest became into being
but let's talk about it specifically for
ipod right so for me
i always had pain the pain of carrying
these cds everywhere right and i had the
joy of music
right
if you could say all of a sudden i could
get the music i love all the time
in a portable package and i can have all
the music i love all the time i was
solving a pain which was for me it was
thousands of these other people might be
10 or 15 cds right and then i can have
the joy of all this music uninterrupted
that was that was taking the pain
making a painkiller for it and then at
the end was a superpower an emotional
superpower that said oh my
this is something different so when you
can actually focus on a pain not of not
and and get a painkiller for it not a
vitamin so the difference between a
painkiller and a vitamin is very clear
one you need i got to get rid of this
pain a vitamin maybe it works maybe it
doesn't maybe somebody needs it maybe
not it's all marketing story right
so you start with the pain give them a
painkiller and hopefully if you can do
it in the right way you give them a
superpower an emotional superpower
that is always and that's the way to to
to know that you're hitting on something
that's really powerful the pain and the
joy exactly um are you always aware
of the pain
so it seems like a lot of great products
it's like we do a lot of painful things
and we just kind of assume
that's the way
it's supposed to be like with much
autonomous vehicles we'll all assume
we're supposed to be driving
right like and it doesn't
you don't think of it as a pain
right
well you've you've habituated it away
yeah you've habituated way for me you
know when i go uh to other places
living in bali or living in paris or
whatever and i'm not driving
i'm walking or reusing a scooter or what
have you different thing and you go oh
my god when you left that environment
because everyone else is driving all the
time you're like that's what you do and
you find out there's other ways of
living and there's freedom when you get
rid of that you're like oh my god i
didn't know
that this was so much better so there's
there's something in the book that's
called i i deemed it the virus of doubt
and what the virus of doubt is is when
there's pain and it's been habituated
away
you use the right marketing messages
to
to bring people back to that initial
experience they had or the initial
experience that they had of that pain do
you remember when the first time you did
blah and it felt like this
right and then you reawaken
that habituated pain
and people it becomes visceral and then
they're like oh
yes i hate that
and then you go now i have the
painkiller and the joy for you yes
that's when it all comes together and it
goes
let me on this on the pain and the joy
that's brilliantly put
you mentioned um
selling and marketing right
marketing dollars
um
i have a love hate relationship with
marketing
like with a lot of things that require
artistic genius
to me the best marketing i suppose
is the product itself and then word of
mouth
so like create a thing that people love
oh absolutely that's fundamental yeah
but so
any other marketing requires genius to
be any extra thing because every
to me
i don't
it's yeah uh maybe you can uh by way of
question because
i'm just speaking off the top of my head
as a consumer uh
what is great marketing what does it
take to to to reveal the the pain and
the joy of a thing okay
it all starts at the beginning
and let me give you i'm going to give
you a couple of different ways of
looking at it okay and again we're going
to might go a little long here so
um
just stay tuned in yeah so the first
thing is the beginning let's start at
the beginning in the early part of my
career you know like general magic and
phillips and what have you
i and especially when i was you know a
teenager when i was like doing making my
own chips and stuff like that i really
worried about just putting cool things
together
i'm like that when i put those two cool
things together as an engineer you go
that's cool
and then i would talk to the other
friends who might be geeks too and they
go yeah that's cool
because we knew the bits
so we put them together and that's a new
way of doing it you're like wow
that's all what
it's not why
why are you doing this we know what
we're doing but we don't know why we're
doing it because we're not articulating
for ourselves because it's just
something we're like putting it together
like yeah that's cool because
because we think we're solving some
problem we have but we're not really
articulating it so what normally happens
and this happens because we invest in so
many companies around the world you have
these brilliant engineers designers
scientists researchers they put together
these
these whats
and then
they develop it develop it develop it
and then at the end they call in
marketing and say now tell a story about
this
and let's get it out to the world okay
what happens then is marketing is like
well why do why do people need this tell
us why people need it and so they create
a story around this product
but the product was born out of what's
not wise
and so they start telling marketing
starts telling a story and it turns out
to be a fictional story usually they say
oh this is going to do these things
the product comes in is delivered and it
falls flat on its face
because the marketing doesn't match the
product because they weren't both
created at the beginning together
right there are what's when you create a
product but there's a lot more y's and
the y's help inform the whats and the
whys also inform the marketing
so at the
that's
what you mean deeply at we should start
at the beginning so
the designer should be also the marketer
the engineer should be the marketer
exactly stop impressing the geek next to
you what is the super power you're
bringing or the pain you're killing for
the you're you're the end customer
right now let's give let's contrast that
think about a movie
a movie starts with a treatment
it has an audience that says the
audience here's the characters here's
the storyline the plot here's the here's
the here's the arc of the story right it
pulls that all out
then there's a script that's written
and that script is then produced and
then you add all the flourishes and what
have you music and graphics and what
have you right and then it comes out and
then there's the marketing of the movie
and that story was created at the
beginning
what you need to do if you're going to
do a great product is create that
treatment for your product and i call
that the press release
do the press release
like the treatment who's the audience
what what features do you have what
pains are you solving for people have
the virus of doubt there to remind them
what pains they have and why you're
solving them the price all of those
things and you use that
as the bar
the measuring stick for what you do
during development because what happens
that along the route you know this
oh we're not going to be able to get
that feature done on time
throw that one overboard we got to hit
the we have to hit the date
oh we're not sure this product's right
yet add another feature
add another fee feature creep right
if you don't have that story you know
you're going to tell at the beginning
you don't have that bar
right
and then at the end you don't know when
you're done if you don't have that story
so you can actually look at that press
release you know you might mod you know
you you change it over time um that
draft
but then when you're done you know the
whats and the whys you have all the
things of the audience and everything
and then you can give that to marketing
and say
well marketing's been along the way
let's be clear but then everybody's in
sync and that's when you can tell a
cohesive non-fictional story about and
the product delivers on that story or
hopefully over delivers on that story
so
in the drafting from the beginning to
the end of the press release what does a
successful team look like who is part of
the draft is it engineers designers
what what's the purpose of a marketing
department in a company small let's say
a small company but more than two people
okay so
from where does the why come from should
it always come from the designer or
should there be a marketing person that
yeah steps in and asks the question so
i'll just keep asking random questions i
know these are great questions okay
so it's because you're just like i'm
like i can't wait to tell you the answer
yeah um so it's in the book as well
but you have to separate out the various
functions of marketing
when
that's what i thought i was like
marketing's marketing you know when i
was and and it's really not there's so
many disciplines just like in
engineering mechanical electrical
software and even software it's you know
use cloud services firmware applications
marketing has that much diversity as
well
okay and you have to honor that
and so
there is marketing communications like
pr press press there is um
social marketing there is a marketing
creative right there's marketing
activation
but there's another thing that also
comes out and people
uh
confuse it with marketing which is
called product marketing or product
management
and product management or product
marketing is the voice of the customer
they're the person
who sits there and listens to what's
going on and the competition in the
marketplace
understanding the needs and those pains
of the customer and they're representing
them in every single meeting so things
don't get off track
right
so that
um and they're creating the messages not
the marketing what happens is there's
messages that product marketing creates
like those are the deep messages like
we need to save 20 of energy let's say
right and then marketing turns that into
something that's with creative and
everything and brings that message
across maybe it doesn't say that but it
comes maybe visually or some other way
so product management does that and
and and holds that press release
along the route and making sure that
we're tracking and then also marketing
is tracking with that press release to
make sure they're not telling a
fictional story right because they could
also add extra adjectives or something
and then the product can't deliver that
it's like no no no no no keeps
everybody's going to be grounded to the
press release to the raw right to the
customer needs yeah right because
they're always representing the customer
so
you have to have a product manager
typically that's the founder
right in the beginning
and then over time you hire a product
management team
to then really
you know watch over this the whole way
and they are talking to customer support
they're talking to engineering they're
talking to design they're talking to
sales and marketing and they are always
in the mix and it's the hardest thing to
hire for oh yeah so it's they have this
a very important job of
developing maintaining the why
exactly why is it the hardest to hire
for because you have to understand you
first nobody reports to you
right you're allowed so you're alone
and you have to build great ties with
all of these different these different
functions yes you have to understand
what they do have be empathetic with
what they do and you have to get have to
project
the customer's empathy or empathy for
the customer to them and tell them why
and why this customer needs us why this
doesn't work and so that they learn more
they're not just doing but they learn
about the customer's point of view and
sit in there and stand in their shoes to
be able to then make better decisions on
the engineering details or the
operational details customer support
details so they understand
the ev if they're not the customer that
it's intended for they start to live
through and through their eyes and see
through their eyes of that customer so
they make better decisions and there's
probably
fascinating beautiful
tensions between that and sort of the
the the engineers oh that's cool sort of
the
you know developing the what uh exactly
and which makes it an extra hard job i'm
sure exactly can i ask a sort of a
little bit of a personal question
one subfield of marketing mentioned
comms in pr
how do i ask that i i can hear your
struggle in your in your thigh
why
or do
the
comms and pr folks sometimes
kill the heart and soul
of of a of the magic that makes a
company or is that is that wrong to say
give me an example
i will say the spirit of the example
which is
uh it feels like often the jobs of of
communications
is to provide caution
it almost it almost works together with
legal to say
yeah we should probably should not
say this we're probably let's be careful
let's be careful
now that makes sense except
in this modern world
authenticity
uh
is extremely valuable
and revealing
the beauty that is in the engineering
the beauty of the
the ideas the chaos of the ideas i think
requires
throwing caution to the wind to some
degree
i agree and
i just find that
boy i mean it's a really so to to push
back on myself i think it's an extremely
difficult job because people hold you
responsible if you're doing
communications
when you take risks right um
and especially when they fail so like
the it's a difficult job so i understand
why people become cautious but to me
communications is about taking big risks
and throwing caution into the wind at
its best because your job
is to communicate
in the long term
communicate the genius the the joy
the the the genius of the products right
and that sometimes is a tension with
caution sorry so i i
uh because i've gotten a chance to meet
a lot of very interesting people and
interesting engineering teams and so on
i look at what they're doing
and i look at what's being communicated
and it's just there's a mismatch because
the communication is a lot more boring
it's like there's something very
like
just straight up boring about the way
they're communicating because of caution
okay
and you have just teed me up for another
diatribe okay i'm gonna get on my i'm
gonna get on my podium here yes please
uh
it all comes out of the leader
if the leader doesn't know how to
storytell or the leader doesn't know how
to do bold storytelling
then
you get even more con conservatism from
the pr and communications folks
because they're always so if you have a
not a bowl leader
they they're always going to be a filter
right they're always going to try to
smooth things out and take off the rough
edges and try so they're going to be
even more if you have a conservative
messaging leader you're going to have
even a more conservative communications
department why because they want to keep
their jobs
okay it's really simple yes they got to
keep their jobs if they say one wrong
thing
it could be the end of it so if you have
very conservative leader they're going
to be even more conservative if you have
a bold leader there will be oh they'll
always take a a little more conservative
bent but you're still going to have bold
communications yeah that's brilliant
okay so it starts with the leader now
that said
when you
you
you think about the messages and the joy
and revealing things right
many of these leaders don't tell great
stories
so what we do at future shape our
investment firm
is we take those scientists all and the
great minds and everything and what do
we surround them with
marketing and communication people and
storytellers to give them the confidence
to tell a much broader story
about the impacts of what they're
creating and how big the global change
can be with those technologies because
usually they don't those leaders who
created those technologies they don't
really know how to communicate really
well and they don't feel very
comfortable in how they speak yeah so
it's interesting because stories and i'm
a huge fan of stories
have you ever read the book story no by
robert mckee
you should read this and this is what i
read when it's 26.
story by robert mckee and it's a book
all about the
waste due script writing
the prototypical
types of scripts drama comedy and how
it's been shown over you know millennia
how these stories are done it's it's a
fascinating thing and it gives you an
insight
to and it's it's written for you know
obviously hollywood and and and movies
and things like that but it's incredibly
useful for what we do um as designers
and engineers and and technology piano
leaders there's some aspect in this
modern day where you know this podcast
and so on
um
what i love is the humans behind the
story too so some part of the story is
the human beings
so humor
drama
heartbreak hope emotions emotions
that's not just about us a painting a
beautiful story that's flawless
it's uh vulnerability yep it's uh you
know being a dreamer
like over promising and then
uh
failing
real life so changing your mind
realizing sort of just the whole of it
and then also being like uh depending of
course where your personality is
um embracing the full richness and the
complexity of the personality of the
leader or the different people involved
i mean that that's all part of it like
you can't just present this
beautiful always pleasantville
view of a product there has to be
this um this humanity that's part of it
the the full roller coaster of the
humanity which i i think is uh been very
difficult for companies to embrace right
not sure why
i'm not maybe it's just an old school
way of doing things like people think
you know that we present a facade
and uh you know we generate the story
and we tell the story as opposed to sort
of um well we learn in especially in the
technical world we present the story as
it's faster it's smaller it's longer
battery life it's it's bits and numbers
and
you know and
metrics
that that resonates
sure with other geeks
what resonates with the the the you know
the planet
it's all emotions right and if you can
bring a great emotional story but with a
great rational story at the same time
why you should do this and it's like oh
my god you bring that superpower that
joy
then it all hangs and there's personal
drama too like
the human right the here's the pain i
had remember that thing
and like i mean just i mean just you
know uh you're
you're obviously
this extremely
well-known human being that's behind a
lot of these
uh great inventions of the technology
world but you're also just a human being
you have a clearly
uh
like a distinct personality that comes
through the like your eyes light up just
the way you communicate is just you
um
some people are more stoic some people
are sure like uh elon is
you know all over the place the chaos
uh
steve jobs
you know there's a very i mean it's hard
to put into words i can be poetic and so
on but there's a very distinct it comes
on stage you know that personality right
there that's not just the product that's
something else too correct and like you
have to reveal that a little bit and
allow people to reveal that a little bit
and just let them be
themselves well
look
why why do i think your podcast is so
amazing because you are yourself
you talk about yourself you bring your
emotions into it and you don't modulate
it
you you're you
right
it comes through it's it's true it feels
right you are you you that you you dress
the way you want to dress you say this
is me and this is all of me and you and
you become vulnerable right it's much
easier to do a podcast like that than
run a very large company correct where a
lot of people would feel the pain if you
make if you say something stupid right
if you so um there's a it's much more
easy to be afraid right and be careful
so
but nevertheless the same applies
um authenticity and risk taking is is is
the only way unfortunately
to be successful in the long term uh let
me just because we're jumping all over
the place uh
i just linger on the ipod sure one of
the great designs
um
broadly speaking in the word design of
all time what what does it take to
design a great product
if you look
who can jump around we could look at
nests we can look at ipod we can look at
iphone
and many of the great things uh you
design but
just
looking at that one transformational
thing
what can you say about what it takes
to do a great design
or maybe what makes a great design
well we talked about you know a
painkiller and we talked about the
we talked about that you know joy that
comes from it
but then there's the behind the scenes
there's the team
there's everyone who brings it to life
brings that story to life
if you have a great story
and you know the why then you can
communicate it to those people who are
working on it
and then they bring their own thing into
it
right it becomes emotional for them too
it's not just a job it's a mission
and so many of the details that are born
out of these
early prototypes these things that you
still haven't given full form to there
may be eighty percent done or maybe even
sixty percent done but you can see
enough in there
then you take those great ideas and you
give the why's to the team
and so that they feel it
they can understand it then they bring
their best and their ideas
to the table and then you can select
from those and you can then start to
um you know
it could be just a pixel change it could
be a slight change on how you do the
audio for the feedback or maybe a curve
on the mechanics or something like that
of how it feels because everybody brings
themselves trying to you know feel this
thing they're not just doing something
that someone told them to do
if you can instill that mission and that
why into that team it doesn't have to be
big you get
i feel a 10x everyone comes together in
a special way
and
um
and
the magic is created you put the love
into it
the customer feels the love on the other
side so the
making the team
like taking him in onto the vision onto
the why
now they feel the all the little details
we think of
the original
ipod
and all the
many generations after all those little
details
are
in them is the emotion of the engineers
and the designers that
it's their baby it's like a knight's
struggling this isn't right like you
said changing little pixels here and
there
changing changing the shape of things
changing the feel of things
like uh the materials
the
i don't know just everything on the
software part of the packaging the words
on the packaging
just everything the words on the website
and always jumping from the very
specific detail problem
to the big picture how the thing feels
the overall always jumping back and
forth what does it look like to the
customer how are we going to implement
it in the most
um you know
efficient way
because you know a lot of stuff you
don't know is some of that stuff is
hacked in
maybe hacked in at the end it might it
it may not be the most beautiful
architecture that a geek would look at
and go oh my god that's so beautiful
because we can look at and visualize
this incredible software stack or
hardware stack some of it could just be
hacked in
you make it better over time but it was
that brilliant thing and we got to get
that in because that's the way you do it
now and we'll make it more efficient
later
maybe this is a good moment to draw a
distinction between design and
engineering and does such a distinction
even exist
are these distinct disciplines or no i
don't think they're just distinct i
think they're different types of design
i think there's you know there's always
this you know this
idea of this oh on the mount designer
and it all comes down and it all flows
down like some magic
it's not there are electrical designs
there's ai designers there is data
scientist designers everybody has design
and there's a chapter in the book all
about that actually that it's not just
you go to the mount and it comes down
and you're enlightened it's each person
brings their their form of design and
their craft because what if they're
really good they're artists in their own
right they're not just engineers they're
not just design they're artists they're
empathetic they really want to bring
their best a lot of the best engineers i
have are not the technical or that i've
worked with are not the technical
gotta get it exactly right they're the
artists they came from music or they
came from other things and they they see
that right when you work with very rigid
engineers
this is the way the only way
those are not the engineers i want to
work with
they're all like a bit artists at heart
right they they understand the practical
practicalness
they don't have to have the rigidity of
this is the way it's done like
where if you're building something new
all new and revolutionary none of us are
experts at it
and if you come with that expert mindset
just tell me and i can give you a story
i should probably give you that story um
about that if you come with the expert
and i'm the expert when you're doing
something no one's ever done before
i don't want you on the team
because we all are learning about
something that has never been
in existence before and we have to bring
that level of vulnerability and openness
to new ideas and new ways of doing
things
throughout the team
so you want people that are able to have
like beginner's mind or whatever like
don't don't come in as an expert what's
the story okay you're not a story okay
all right no i i can tell it's just all
right
so
so
you know you asked what were these risks
you know like on the early ipod and
there's there was there's a few big
risks like one and this this doesn't go
in the story but like putting rotating
media in your pocket and it could drop
at any time what happens there and like
you can damage because the heads and the
hard drive media are so close it smacks
it's dead right so that was one big one
like is holy [ __ ] right so that was
something we and we had to design
special tests and everything and special
software on that but then there was
another one which was at the early days
the way the first generations of ipods i
had to hack
the i had to hack the ide interface to
the hard drives
so i was like okay what we're going to
use is we're going to use this chip for
hard drive um hard drive to make a hard
drive you had to have a chip that did
firewire to a hard drive okay and then
that would become a portable hard drive
well then we had up
we had the mp3 player and and the user
interface and everything so there was
times when it was just this hard drive
and there was times when it was a mp3
player and i had to hot switch between
what the hard drive thinks it was
talking to yeah right so designed this
thing tore it apart done all this stuff
and i was like
you know maybe i'm going to screw up ide
and there's something there's some holes
i'm going to see
so i go who's the expert at apple who
understands ide and everything
so
this person comes over
the mass storage specialist comes over
and i put on the whiteboard and said
here's how we're going to do this thing
and here's the commands and this is how
it hot switches and everything he's like
that's never going to work yeah
i was like what it was never going to
work i said well let me go over here and
show you this right here i haven't
prototyped and it's been working for
days i just wanted to see if you're
going to have it find any holes in the
thing right didn't even get and he just
stormed out of the room and never never
even yeah right that's hilarious i've
had a lot of experience like this with
experts like for example this ridiculous
room
um i had uh
i had a person and
many people like this that
i showed them here's the situation
you know it's acoustics acoustics yeah
they're like no no no no this is
horrible
this
does not this is not gonna work
the reflection
the the curtains are not gonna stop uh
the reflex there's a bunch of
terminology they're telling me um it's a
similar kind of situation as the idea
which i was like no i
listen
i just need to see is there major issues
and they're like a low-hanging fruit
that are fixable and major holes i
should be aware of not like that's 100
000 to upgrade to upgrade for what exact
purpose
what not why yeah exactly exactly the
why the focusing on the on the story and
the content on the the why the why do i
and that that actually i've experienced
that unfortunately in the artistic
realms too which is like
photography and videography
cinematography uh
it's interesting i talked to
photographers that are quote-unquote
experts
and it's always about the so much of the
focus is on
the equipment
the equipment behind
the sensors and the lighting
and it's like all right
all right
but um
what about
what about the feeling
of the story you create visually
the difference between a
a movie that's really well told
and it doesn't have all the effects and
everything versus maybe some of the
superhero movies we see all the time
which is good luck if there's a story
but man there's a lot of action and and
cgi
well that's that's right and that
and there's also value to the to to
those right cgi
superhero can tell a better story but
you have to have a good story to begin
with
sure exactly but it it's if you're
focused on the story i guess you need to
start with a story you need to start the
story and if you bring in experts
they can often be
uh detrimental
i guess to the why they're they're too
good at doing the what well you can
bring in experts for why there's lots of
experts for why
too many times we get experts for what
yes and then they only focus on the what
and so you so they come with the specs
and feeds and the the numbers and all
the other stuff but what you're really
asking for is i need somebody about the
why in understanding what we're trying
to get done here and fitting the what's
into that why
right that's why i i do think that
i i
one of the qualities that i really enjoy
for people to work with is like humility
for a particular problem when you
approach it
basically i don't know how to solve this
but we're going to figure it out as
opposed to oh i've solved this thing
many many times before i know exactly
what to do uh humility before the chaos
sort of having having an open mind that
this is going to require a totally new
way of doing uh things it's a really
nice quality to see um
you know you're one of the fascinating
humans in the history of silicon valley
steve is another one of those so those
two humans came together for a time to
work together
what was it like working with steve jobs
what uh aspect of his behavior and
personality
let's say brought out the best in you
pushing you
really pushing you relentless on the
details
challenging you for the right reasons
it wasn't bullying it wasn't demeaning
he would critique the work not judge the
person at least not in front of them
or inside of a you know in front of a
group or anything like that i know it
was really that attention to detail and
he when he would make a decision you
know there are when you make the first
version of anything something
revolutionary there are a lot of
opinion-based decisions
and there's only one or two people three
people who hold those opinion-based
decisions and what they should be
and
when you have those opinions
and you're trying to work with the team
to
implement those
decisions
you have to really tell the why of those
decisions just don't go do it but why
it's there so you can feel part of that
um decision you can understand
what were the trade-offs of the
different other
answers to that opinion right
and say this is the reason why we picked
the what we picked because it's this for
the customer or this for the overall
story what have you so that you felt
really good
because a lot of times most people want
a data driven decision
but with v1s you don't get data
right maybe in a b2b you could a little
bit because you can talk to customers
but you can't do that with a consumer
property one version one b2b business
the business versus what's the
alternative
uh business to consumer v
okay
which is defining centers
yes yes so and when you say data driven
decisions versus what
opinion-based decisions so like gut you
have to use you don't have any
um
you can't fall back on any data or any
previous history to kind of inform you
of what's going on right and so if you
look at most
companies who are paralyzed and cannot
make new innovations and new products
it's because they're trying to turn and
this is what i saw at philips they're
trying to turn opinion-based decisions
into data-driven decisions so they don't
lose their jobs
so if you look at management consulting
management consulting is all about
taking those opinion-based decisions
giving them to someone else to turn into
data that comes back to them and says
they can blame the management
consultants yeah when something goes
wrong as opposed to it wasn't me
yeah right
when you need to have to tell that story
you have to understand that especially
v1 you need to be able to
um
articulate those those
opinion-based decisions and you need to
own them
and if you fail with some of them you
didn't get it right you you then own
them and fix them and move on right
version one of the ipod wasn't perfect
version one of the iphone wasn't perfect
we got a lot of opinion-based decisions
wrong
but as you go through it because you got
more data because v2 you had data on
those original opinions and then you
were able to then modulate off of that
right and you still have new opinions
because those are differentiators that
you that we call differentiators that
the things that you know move the move
the product forward
in its evolution but at the revolution
stage opinions opinions opinions no data
and so you have this discussion you and
steve
and the whole in the stage and the whole
team
with
opinions and there you have to be harsh
i i wouldn't say harsh but you have to
be very determined right you know there
there are two real opinion-based
decisions that happen on the iphone
one was
the keyboard
should we have a key hardboard keyboard
or should we have a virtual keyboard
the blackberry was the number one
productivity messaging device of its
time
it was called a crackberry for a reason
because people loved it because it had
it was easy to type and you know they
could get their work done
but when you're saying we're going to
move from that everyone's talking about
that in the market and you say we're
going to move to a virtual keyboard and
it's not going to work as well as the
hardware keyboard
that's an opinion-based decision right
because the data is telling you
yeah all the best sales are over here
god that takes cuts
it takes guts but you have to look at it
from a different point of view and this
is how
i learned to come to understand this
because i had been building you know
virtual keyboards before and i knew
you know the goodness and the badness in
them right but he was like look those
are productivity devices we're making it
where ours is born out of an
entertainment device and productivity
right
we need to show full screen videos we
are going to have apps here not apps but
our apps the apple apps because there
were no app store yet are going to take
over the whole screen you want a full
screen web browser you don't want one
that's like half of the device is just a
keyboard maybe you don't need that
keyboard in every instance so we want
that part of the screen to change based
on the tool you may need at the time and
maybe it's just full view right so you
have to go and understand it's a
different type of device just because
that's that and it's successful for that
reason the crackberry for the keyboard
that's not the only thing you're going
to do with this device because people
only did messaging and maybe a few phone
calls right this was going to be so much
more it was going to be an entertainment
web browsing device so you wanted those
tools to go away but it wouldn't be as
good
as the hardware keyboard so that's an
opinion but let me give you another
opinion based decision that got turned
around before it shipped
steve said no sim plot
i don't want any slots we're going to
make it very pure
johnny was like of course no slots
johnny
and
we all looked around and go that doesn't
work
you can't do that well why does variety
and then he would always and this was
the magic of steve like when you said no
that doesn't work you go well why does
verizon not have any sim slots right
they showed that you can do a mobile
phone with those limits you're like
okay here we go and so
a few days later we come back with you
know and and so uh product marketing
voice of the customer engineering we all
come back with all the data showing how
many
how many data networks and
mobile networks required sim cards
versus did not
and what the trends were and we showed
the data
and that killed the or excuse me brought
back the sim slot on the original iphone
because we're like
because he was just like we're going to
tell a t to not use a sim yeah right
we're going to just tell them to do it
differently
right but we were like if we want this
thing to go anywhere around the world
you want to put that friction in people
are going to move from place to place
you know they have different sims
because of the prices and all that stuff
we had to show all of that data and then
that opinion-based decision got turned
into a data-driven decision and it and
the sim slot obviously showed up so
those are two ver at the very same time
yeah right
opinion can hold and so can data over
rule opinion when data does exist for a
v1 but the at the end of the day you
don't know what the right answer is
so
doing no
sim card slot
may have been the right decision
we won't know
because maybe if that was
the decision
then like many times throughout apple's
history you basically changed the tide
of how technology is done
yeah absolutely you know you never know
apple started wi-fi people don't
understand wi-fi came out of there there
was no wi-fi in 2001 apple started wi-fi
and then everyone else you know got onto
on board if you look at now where we're
going we're going to phones without sim
slots
because we have e sims right and now the
sim slot is becoming legacy legacy as a
legacy port
that legacy port will probably be gone
by
six maybe ten years he'll be gone i'm
pretty sure of that
um because it's so much easier for
carries they don't have to have physical
things to go out and right
so right now it's just the early days
but it will happen and it will go its
way it'll fall away but it will take
time you just couldn't do it back then
so timing is essential here but at the
end of the day it's opinions and that's
where the genius is sometimes the data
tells you one thing but the data at the
end of the day does represent the past
exactly and the future may be different
than the past right
uh sometimes there's wisdom in the in
the past and sometimes
it's actually representative of
something that should be
uh overcome and uh progress looks like
leaving that stuff behind like um right
the headphone jack right
i mean that when uh when different folks
were getting rid of
the headphone jack
boy that i would love to be a a fly in
the wall of those
oh discussions we had that oh
that was that was a discussion that
happened almost every year
yeah that was an every year should we
get rid of headphone jacks on the ipod
yeah right when are wireless headsets
going to happen what it right and it
took years to build all the right
protocols the chips all those things to
make the experience that is the i
airpods today
right
to say have the confidence because
bluetooth was good but it wasn't apple
like so nat it's like we got to make our
own chips we got to make our own
software stacks now we have the
confidence to remove the headphone jack
and actually make you pay 200 more for
your iphone that you were just paying
because it's a headphone jack now we've
grown our revenue we've given a new
experience to the user right and
ta-da you know it's just it's magic and
now if the world's transformed to
everyone you know moving to that right
but it took years to understand the
problem develop the technology to and
not just rush it to market to get a half
experience but to get it right and
refine it then ship it and only then
after
it was probably four or five years in
development just like the m1 processor
right
that was a work from 2008
right
grinding away grinding away grinding
away then saying okay now we have the
confidence we're doing our own silicon
for all the iphones and ipods
ipads and such
now we're going to turn to the mac and
make sure we have the best processor
right not just that we have the best
integrated design team
and then
saying we're gonna you know and then
besting everyone making sure the
software's
and the hardware is designed at the same
time making sure the kernels all those
things are
are gonna use the best efficiency
and then popping it out
and then it feels seamless it's magic
there were no
as far as i could tell unless you were
in real esoteric drivers or something
like that it just worked it was magic
like the transit it was not even a speed
bump it was not even a crack in the road
so um perhaps famously steve had a bit
of a temper
steve jobs
would would you say his
particular personality in this aspect
was constructive or destructive
in the process of
shaping these opinion-based
ideas
so in
build i write a chapter called [ __ ]
yes
and you lay out beautifully
the types of [ __ ]
and uh maybe you could speak to
the constructive and the destructive
types of [ __ ] okay
so there's really two delineations that
i
that i've found of you know real
fundamental ones and that is
again the why
why do i feel this person is an [ __ ]
okay they might not be
i feel this is a person who's an [ __ ]
are they motivated by their ego
or are they motivated by their mission
something they're trying to do that's
and doing in service of something else
right
sometimes those lines can be blurry but
it's usually pretty clear
when it's when it's ego motivated
you're it's clear they're just trying to
get up in the ranks push people down
shove people aside i think we saw a
president do that on a stage once
um
you know i'm me and i'm the you know i'm
the
the the guy right and i'm gonna prove it
by pushing everyone away and being
nefarious or what have you either
passively aggressive or aggressively
aggressive
but they're doing about themselves
there's another one which is someone
who's so attentive to detail and
unrelenting
that they're trying to get the right
things for the customer or the in
service of their mission and they want
to make sure we fulfill those things
right
and they really care they don't
micromanage all the details but they
micromanage the details where the
customer it touches the customer in some
way
people who work with those types of
people who are unrelenting and push you
and might make you upset a lot of times
it's a knee-jerk reaction to go they are
an [ __ ]
get off my back you're
right and you're protecting your ego
because what's happening is that person
is usually pushing you beyond your
boundaries
they see something
that we can do or you can do that you're
just either
not wanting to do for whatever reason
you're not confident in that
you you're like i don't want to take the
extra time and say no we need to get
that done and pushing you
okay
and so
when
we came to those areas it wasn't just a
one-on-one it could be steve against the
team going we need glass instead of
plastic on the front face of the iphone
and we're going to do this
and we're like god
you know and so we did it
and he pushed us because he didn't know
all the details but he could see in our
minds that we're like
yeah we could probably yeah we could
probably but man it's really putting us
in risk and we we laid out the risks for
him and he's like i'm willing to take
those risks
we'll do that we're like we might be
three months late he's like this is so
important we need to stay on time
you know but it would be all the time
push push push i re it reminds me of
like kids growing up and me as growing
up you know when your parents push you
to make you grow beyond your boundaries
your personal boundaries and you're like
god damn it i'm sad
you know but they do it for the right
reasons now let's see it's not bullying
it's not about bullying it's not about
demeaning
it's about either pushing you to another
part of the mission that needs to get
done or it's about critiquing your work
but not judging you yes well there's a
lot to say there so one
uh it's fascinating it's it's really is
fascinating and you laid out a very nice
picture but it's
it does feel like there's sometimes gray
areas which is why it makes all this
very complicated so one question i have
for you in terms of glass on the iphone
um
how important is it that
like steven that case
is right
because
i could argue
each side it seems like in one sense
just having a strong vision and opinion
is already going to make everybody grow
even if it turns out to be the wrong as
long as you are sort of standing your
ground
um
you know napoleon invading russia or
something in the winter
like it's just not gonna be it's not
that good right this is not a good idea
but i'm gonna hold do that and then once
you decide you go all in
and then from that even if the whole
team knows it's the wrong decision just
sticking by it powering through you will
learn through the pain of it like
everybody will learn so that's one side
the other is
maybe
um the [ __ ] the vision driven [ __ ]
uh gets to be
more and more of an [ __ ] if they have
a track record
of
through that process having built people
up having made the correct decisions
they can't they're not allowed to be an
[ __ ] they're in rare air and no one
can challenge them right right
steve was never that that's the great
thing he was he was never
unchallengeable you could challenge him
now let's
now this the the plastic to glass story
is a perfect example of this
so at the beginning of the project well
before we were going we had always had
these things about you know plastic
front ipods these kinds of things these
scratches and all that stuff
so we said are we going to have a glass
or a plastic display
a cover for the display because the
display was glass underneath it
we argued back and forth about glass
versus plastic and then we all landed
together on plastic
okay the original decision was plastic
and the reasons were okay we don't want
to make a mistake glass can break
you know
people drop them all the time
so we don't want to have a fragile
device
because
you're going to be using even more than
a music player right
and you're going to be holding your head
and putting in your pocket and misses
and all that stuff
so we went down the road with plastic
when it was shown when the product was
shown at mac world
in 2007 the first time that was plastic
we had just enough of them in the field
at the time we started to start seeing
light scratches on the
plastic
reviewers who didn't have the device yet
because it was behind glass if you if if
you remember 2007 the jesus phone comes
up and no one could even touch them you
could just look at it in this beautiful
museum quality box like it came from the
future or whatever the past it was like
oh and you just looked and that was all
you got but then people said well what
screen is what covers on that you know
reviewers who knew better you know and
they're like oh it's plastic and they
were like really
and so there was enough of a doubt there
and then when we started to do it and
then steve changed the frame of
reference of the question or of the
result of what the customer would think
and he was like
if we designed it with plastic
and it's in their pocket all the time
and it gets scratched by coins lightly
scratched or by keys or something like
that
that is a design problem
we need to fix the that was our bad
if they go off and drop it
or even slightly drop it
and it cracks
it's the customer's fault and they have
much lower
they have less likelihood to complain
yes they'll complain but they're part of
that
of that failure
yes oh that's fascinating and then
there's truth to that right
because then they were part of why it
failed whereas the design they didn't do
anything wrong it was just sitting in
their pocket and it's you know it's
scratching
and that's normal use
abnormal use has been dropped and we're
like
oh now we get it and so we all moved to
that mindset when you framed the problem
and the solution in that way versus the
original framing where we all landed on
plastic so
and then he was unrelenting on that but
we all had moved
and we have moved mindset and we
understood the why and we marshaled
together
and then by the end of june and it was
crazy the mechanical product design
teams
sourcing all of us all the the partner
corning pulled together to make that
happen because it was the right reason
right so this
you know you look at these stories and
you hear just the top line
rumors of the takeaways but that's not
usually how it all happened of like one
leader was
that's not how steve was now i've seen
leaders who were just
pounding you know and just had no
real empathy for the team and
understanding the why and it's just it
is the way i want it right i am the
supreme leader
that wasn't like that
when he just had a very strong opinion a
very strong opinion but it was
challengeable
it was challengeable and if you came
with the right thing you know it was you
could you could modulate that but you
had to come with a team it couldn't just
be you and you had to become a team and
data and to overcome because it was a
very strong opinion and there's personal
quirks of character like you said
days and good days bad days and good so
there's also the three options you said
you you notice that the third option is
always going to be the one that's picked
uh sure those kinds of idiosyncrasies
idiosyncrasies and that so that brings
up another thing okay
uh
you said challenge the idea not the
person
you know
i'm somebody who has a you know i have a
temper i've i use colorful language and
so on when i'm on teams i work in my
private life i'm much calmer and so on
but i get when i get really passionate
with engineering teams
and i've been called an [ __ ]
i mean i am distinctly aware that you
cross lines uh often
um
there's like levels right sure
you know you could it has to do with
language and how language is heard so
for example you could say a lot of stuff
to me you could swear you could say
stuff that sounds pers like
like i don't know
lex
sometimes i think you're the dumbest
human on the face of the earth or
something i don't know
this sounds very personal right but i'm
not going to take that personally i
understand what's being said and then
i'm also noticed that there's other
people that take stuff more personally
this has to do with teams and figuring
out like okay who's going to take
certain words personally or not and you
have to know that's what takes makes a
great coach a great leader a mentor you
have to you have to like
factor all that in but it just there's
something about just being an [ __ ]
and um
being passionate and really driven
that sometimes you do cross lines
and that's
i don't know what to do with that
because it feels like it comes with the
territory like you have
it seems like
you can't just have a perfectly
optimized
no
no absolutely not that we're humans yeah
we're humans we don't have a program
everyone's programmed the same way to
react the same way to given stimulus
right yeah so
you know you said i don't know if this
was a real example but you said oh
you're the dumbest human on earth or
whatever i would never say that
absolutely never and if someone said
that to me or i saw someone else say
that to another person on the team
absolutely not that is not allowed
because that's judging someone you may
be heated and you can get heated and you
can say it in your intonation but to
then
try to put a label on it and put a label
on a person that is not allowed so if
you let that kind of culture happen
and it becomes somewhat
you know sometimes it's in jest
you know it has to be very much ingested
and those two people have to have a
really good working relationship so
but other than that i'm sorry it's going
to be a lot more
you could say a septic in that way that
you're not going to add that stuff in
but you can do it with all other types
of ways without saying that because then
people who do react to that kind of
language
and don't have those shields because
they don't might not might not have that
stream confidence level that you do and
you can just brush it off you can that
can be very
cancerous in a team because people then
meme that and then they see oh that's
the right way to be you got to snuff
that out and you got to be that
you got to be that change or that model
that you want to show the team
yes it's too even if it doesn't affect
me it's going to affect a a significant
enough fraction of
brilliant people where that shouldn't be
part of the culture exactly and and
other people see that happen and then oh
i guess that's acceptable right just
like politics in the workplace is that's
acceptable or not i call it out exactly
when i see it in front of everyone right
because
it's just another ego driven thing you
have to set the tone
as a leader for what you want your
organization to be and how to it gets
reflected in the world and you have to
uphold that and you can sure you can
have an excursion outside of that but
you have to go back and say i'm sorry
yeah
yeah you have to apologize heal and said
i was not the person i wanted to be that
day i'm really sorry
yeah this is and even in front of the
team and have that humility and say
we're all human here and just because
i'm the leader doesn't mean i don't make
mistakes so have the self-awareness
apologize exactly
and that that's that's also part of the
culture
um oh yeah how are you different from
steve as a leader and designer so you
you've spoken about sort of what made
you stronger which is he was able to
challenge he was able to push you to
bring out the best well i come from the
technical angle right
deep technology software hardware
systems thinking you know implementation
all that stuff so i so i have a
different ben he
wanted to be an engineer started but
really he was much better at all the
other things the storytelling the
interfacing and and being the voice of
the customer and being that product
marketer in a way right that we talked
about i grew into being the product
marketing and marketing he came really
out the other way right and never got
really deep technically so that's two
different mindsets no one's not better
or worse it's just that's how it is and
it takes all kinds to to
and and all kinds can do great designs
did it manifest itself differently just
the fact that you came from those diff
uh different places absolutely like what
uh
so like the discussion about glass on
the iphone was probably had a different
flavor to it sure when you started
getting into the technical details
enough so you're getting the third order
technical details and he can't argue
with that anymore
he's like okay
you know at some point he's like i can't
win this war like the and he learned
that very early on because he didn't
like the way
the look of the macintosh um board the
pcb was laid out
he wanted to be beautiful on the outside
and on the inside he's like why are all
these wires running this way why doesn't
it have all this symmetry and we have to
make it beautiful on the inside and and
the even the traces on the boards have
to look a certain way so the teams made
the board they knew that would work and
then they made the board that the way
steve wanted it and that didn't work and
then steve instantly figured out like at
some point don't micromanage every
single detail there's some things he
doesn't know enough about so he would
get out of that but that was one of
those instances where he pushed really
hard and that's his opinion so they said
okay we're going to make it a
data-driven decision we're going to make
both i'm going to show you the results
right and then from there he didn't get
into those details so from that you
could have a great challenge right
because then you could get those data
and say we can't do that and let me show
you why or we can do that and then steve
would go you can't do that you're like
oh we can do that let me show you right
so there's certain times when you were
like bringing something to reality that
he didn't think could exist
right so
it was that it was always that creative
tension that interaction that was so
successful right i think but there was
one other fundamental thing that was
different
and that it graded on the team
and that i made sure and i learned from
to not do
and and i over maybe overdue now in the
opposite direction which is
when there's a great idea that comes
from the team
acknowledge that person and go that is a
great idea as the leader you know the
opinion driven that's a great idea let's
build on that let's see if that can do
that or it's a great idea but not for
now put it aside but call out when
people have great ideas because it's
infectious and that means not ideas that
come bubble up to the customer level but
inside the organization people like they
get rewarded for their ideas and say
that's a great one
steve was always like
you give an idea
and he would go hmm okay
i don't know
the next day 24 hours later it would
come back with slight modifications i've
had this genius idea
right and it's sooner or later we'd we'd
look around the table and we'd like roll
our eyes and go here we go again so it
demotivates you from generating ideas a
little bit yeah well you know we got
used to it but you know later on in the
team yeah you know it was just not
it it just it doesn't want to bring the
best right because if you're always like
er the reaction is never that's a genius
idea
it was always like it was either
negative or
neutral
right yeah then it doesn't it doesn't
have that same emotional effect that you
want you to bring your best yeah
sometimes it's fun when people get
excited about it just yeah yeah yeah you
kind of build on top excitement it could
be but coupled with sort of harshness
when the idea is bad and you call out
the bad ideas too so it's the good and
the bad
oh you could say
you don't you don't have to say bad
ideas like maybe not now let's table
that for later let's discuss it or say
that's a decent idea but did you think
about that idea this way not just no or
yes but let's talk about why that might
not be applicable in this case so that
they can learn so the next time they
bring the next idea they can modulate
and understand and start seeing through
the opinion based decision makers or the
databases to bring it and bring better
formatted arguments or ideas so that you
have better chance of success the next
time yeah right you gotta train through
those moments you to teach those are
teaching moments
yeah
moments i aspire to be that kind of
person i'll usually say that that that
idea is [ __ ]
that is the like the like and then you
that i remember that that this brilliant
person just gave that really shitty idea
so i remember to make sure the next time
they give a good idea really compliment
that good idea but i personally
i mean it's emotion but i i call out the
really shitty ideas but you should call
it the really great ones yeah if you let
the pendulum swing both ways then
everybody goes he's balanced yeah it's
always one way
why bring any idea i'm all about the
pendulum right
you gotta have both the joy and the pain
don't just give me pain all the time
uh so you mentioned the glass and the
iphone so you're one of the not just the
ipod not just nest you you were one of
the key figures in the creation of the
iphone what's the interesting aspects
what what's the good the bad and the
ugly of the origin story of the iphone
um again this is a netflix series that
spans multiple seasons
but what changed my flight please yeah
what wisdom what's
interesting memories you have from the
final so
uh the the the pain and the joy
that that was foundational to the uh
ipod
uh the all the cds you had to lug around
um what was
the pain and the joy and the vision of
the iphone in your mind in the mind of
the team
and steve's mind and so on
well
you know there's multiple pains you have
to also look there's not just customer
pain but there's business pain
okay and it's about the so apple now
is getting out of that place where it
was in 2001. now people are starting to
pay attention apple's starting to get in
the culture again it's becoming relevant
cash is starting to flow ipod is 60 of
that
of the
of the revenue total revenue of apple
doing on 85 market share you're starting
to get a win at your back you got
confidence like apple had been beaten
down since probably the first time the
mac was since the mac
it was a beaten company ever since the
mac so we're talking
15 years at that point
right this is the first time you're
seeing likes and steve wood proudly came
in front of us and said
today i can tell you all the employees
we are now out of debt we paid off our
debt
it was a joyous moment
for him
right and then ultimately for our team
because no more debt
it's wonderful right
so now what you have is you have this
successful thing changing the face of
apple
and you hear these
heavy stomping footsteps
of the mobile phone industry
boom
and it's the feature phones at that time
they're adding cameras they're adding
color displays they're seeing the
success of the ipod going
that's just music we have some storage
we can load music on our phones and we
can do what the ipod does plus more
boom
boom
yeah right and you're like and how many
mil hundreds of millions of them are
being sold at that point it wasn't
billions yet but it was still you know
100 million 200 million a year
ipod hadn't gotten there it was
4 20 40 50 million something like that
so now you're like okay what are we
gonna do about this you know goliath
who wants to take our lunch right
the schoolyard bully
and so
well there was one let's partner with
them
so
itunes music store was there
all of these phones are going to need
music
so
they can come to the itunes music store
and get that music for those phones
because it wasn't just about the
hardware player at that point it was
about the software that you need on the
desktop and the content that you needed
to download so now apple had multiple
legs of the stool as steve would always
refer to it
so now the mobile phone industry okay
we're going to work with them
they are going to make a red an ipod
shuffle basically
inside of a phone can i have 99 songs
total and they're going to come to our
store and you're going to i was like
okay great it's all gonna be well and
good and that became the motorola rocker
project
it was
apple motorola getting together there's
gonna be software on the on this
smartphone or not smartphone but feature
phone to cook to itunes to get your
music it wasn't even downloadable over a
cloud or anything because that wasn't
available yet there wasn't
data networks yet
um
it was a disaster from the beginning
two different cultures
two different types of leadership styles
uh not necessarily the most competent
engineers on on on on the other side
and it turned out to be an absolute
horrible disaster
i watched the pains because i luckily i
didn't have to be part of it i watched
the pains on jeff robin's face each time
we would meet and he would be like
these guys are just you know like
really do we have to do this steve and
he's like we're contractually obligated
and when it came out on stage and steve
showed it it was maybe a one minute you
know steve loves those extended you know
like drawn up it might have been a one
minute two minute kind of thing and he
literally threw that phone out of his
hand as fast as he could yeah right
because it was horrible so that so there
was the pain of we're not gonna partner
so if we can't partner with these guys
we have to become one of them
to actually compete yeah to save the
thing that is bringing apple from you
know that 15 years of malaise
right
so then from that
we were
made
a prototype of an ipod plus phone a
classic with um well it was an ipod but
had a phone inside with all the music
and all the other stuff and you use your
headset
wired headset to do the audio right
there was another project
at the same time because we were doing
videos in the uh the itunes music store
itunes video store
for music videos and movies
and it would be a full screen ipod so
instead of the the classic the way you
know it um it would be full screen and
it would have a virtual click wheel
you'd have a virtual like single touch
touch screen that you could scroll right
think of maybe an i an iphone like you
knew it right and then there was a third
project going on not in those two were
going on in my team but the third
project going on
was the multi-touch screen
technology to drive a
uh mac tablet
and so that mac tablet that that touch
screen technology
um there was just way too much you had
to change on the software and everything
to be able to use a tablet right we see
this all the time like people like
there's not enough tablet apps today
that are modified for tablet they're
just phone apps that are grown up right
so then they would just be mac
touch stuff so you'd have to have a
whole developer community that probably
wasn't the best place to take that
technology first so you take that
technology marry it with the full screen
ipod and the phone stuff we were working
because the ipod phone with a rotary
dial was just like a rotary phone we
couldn't make that interface work well
for data input
um you put those three together and now
is where those those three things that
then created the form
or the technology and the form inside
what would become the iphone
married with a bunch of low-level
software from the ipod and manufacturing
software and drivers and communication
stuff
combined with
a very reduced
frankenstein mac os
and i mean that in the the mess the best
way it means it wasn't mac os just
changed a little it was totally things
were hacked out and changed and think
new code was inserted and it really was
a
a whole set of things from all different
places
to make that first iphone os and then
there was another team working on the
apps
and then another team working on the
design of how it looked overall between
all that stuff so all of those things
came together to create what we know as
the first generation iphone and those
are all probably fascinating engineering
challenges correct and great teams like
the creating frankenstein os
that's fascinating because you're
simplifying simplifying but then you're
just pulling different stuff from and
you're basically inventing i mean
they're probably not thinking of it that
way but
a new era of computing a new kind of
computer it really is frankenstein right
and you didn't have to run mac software
if you look at some of the other
smartphones of the time like
windows and stuff they were like we need
to make sure it runs excel and it runs
word or something like that in some
reduced thing this was like no no no no
this was born out of entertainment so we
didn't have to go and take all the same
application you know uh all those other
ones was about compatibility this was
about a whole new way of being
what did you think about
um
the steve jobs presentation of the the
iphone
the the sort of
the first iphone
you know phone uh internet communicator
and the ipod in your pocket they're
going to sort of present
announcing three new products
kind of thing and then saying that it's
all in one just this is a good example
one of the sort of
historic
presentations of a product
clearly there's like some showmanship
that works some reason it works right it
doesn't always work it often doesn't
work but it did in in this case it often
did for steve what like how did that
feel
um
what part of the actually
uh
the design process
was that presentation
you know what i mean like from the early
because you said for sure so consider
the why the press release at the very
exactly
steve was doing that the entire time he
was working on that story from day one
yeah he was pitching us this this this
and then this and and then he would look
at our faces because you wouldn't most
people wouldn't at least if you're
working for him wouldn't tell him what
you really thought of what he was saying
but he would look at your faces yeah and
then he would talk to a few real trusted
confidence outside of the
uh outside of the organization and see
what they thought right and they could
give him feedback on it and they could
really challenge him but they could he
would also look at their faces and go
and so when you see that
then he would modulate it and change it
slightly and change so he was working
during all of that time on the story and
the storytelling
right and the whys
while we're working on that and helping
us refine it just like the switch from
plastic to glass right
all the time working on that so when he
comes out on stage he does something
that every marketer is told not to do
say these three things are now combined
in one
that is like the
that they say that that is the laziest
form of storytelling possible for
marketing
right yeah right but it was the best one
because it was all those pains it was
like i want my ipod but i want my
communications and i want my internet
browsing because i want it on the go so
i can look up things because it was
information
and when you were on the road you had a
laptop you had an ipod and you had a
phone that and you had to carry all of
these things with you at once
now we're going to solve that pain
for you and put it all together so he
was just showing you the pain and
viewing that virus of doubt and going
it's now in this one magical thing
and he could come up and masterfully
tell that story because he told it
almost every day
to all of these people inside very
quietly and then it was just
right it was like a you know a tony
award-winning play that had been worked
on for 10 years but also the human came
through the timing it was all that it
was a little bit and of course he was
dramatic at certain points and he would
raise his voice and a wry smile or
whatever it was
all those touches he was an actor as
well as a storyteller yeah and that but
but it was the truth
right
the truth came through it was a
non-fiction story and then he added
those personal flourishes on top of it
for dramatic effect
it's amazing
so there's a designer you mentioned
johnny ave
you both are brilliant designers great
human beings there were some battles
fought
in you in the distant past between the
two of you
uh looking back what is the positive
characteristics of johnny that made you
a better person and designer
having worked with him
watching the process that the design
team
that johnny led
i don't know where because that was over
years i didn't see all of those things
but watching the design process of
really because it was really a team that
was about materials it was about form it
was about colors it was about these
physical characteristics
it it when we talked about this earlier
was design what is design designs
everywhere okay so what they were really
focused on was form
how the feel was how it looked the
aesthetics the physical aesthetics
and watching going through that process
i learned so much in that process
about how to do colors
how to do materials how to
think
deeply about
curves
right and shadows
and how it would look not just in your
hand but how it would look in the
photograph you were going to take from
marketing
right so how it would look how it would
feel
all of it it was it was all of those
physical things
around that and watching the process to
get there
that was enlightening for me right it
opened my mind to go oh okay
just like there's a process for all
these other things it wasn't just
magic and you say
ah there it is it was really a process
of refinement you know of opening the
funnel at the beginning and refining
down over time to get to that final
final and selecting and doing the
selection and certain types you could
certain times they were opinion-based
design
details but a lot of data a lot of
data-driven designs of what can we what
can we deliver in volume what can we do
different things so you always had these
constraints that you had to work with
under and sometimes
they uh and the team not just i would
say we need this we're like we can't
deliver that but maybe we were able to
work together to find different design
characteristics and different
implementation characteristics that
could
get to that point without what they were
describing and instead of
yes yes yes no no no let's find some
other way to solve the problem together
yeah is
and i've seen this um
and several companies have more closely
interacted with like tesla as an example
sometimes
you know talking about curves
sometimes it's very painful on the
engineering side
to deliver a very specific kind of
absolute thing and
one question that comes up in my mind is
like well how far should we go to try to
deliver
a tiny adjustment in a curve
in the curvature or in um
like the whatever the form factor is in
the color of the material
when the cost is like 10x to deliver
not financially but just like you know
yeah there are companies to do it how
many problems still have to solve
um
i don't know i don't know if you can say
any wisdom to that because it because
when you're thinking about curves you're
designing in the space of ideas you're
like platonic forms kind of thing uh not
always grounded to like how much this is
uh how much pain is going to be involved
in delivering this but that's
as you should perhaps because then
uh if you're always thinking about the
pain required to deliver
this thing you you'll be too
conservative you wouldn't do the wild
ideas
right exactly but you have to understand
again the why behind it and at
nest when we had limited resources
you know putting a screwdriver in the
box a custom
designed screwdriver in the box was born
out of those experiences i had at apple
and seeing how you can create something
that's emotional it's part of marketing
and it's part of the product experience
overall even though it it seems
extraneous
i went back and made the design team
uh and the mechanical team changed some
curves on the nest protect the smoke and
co detector we did at nest
after they had already tooled it and i
said they're saying this cost more i
said it doesn't look right there is a
but they're like oh well we had i said
no you're going to go back and you're
going to make that change i told you you
want we needed to do it we had a better
looking model that is going to get done
i know it's going to be a terrible cost
to you but we already had this
discussion and that's the way it's gonna
have to be and i'm sorry but it is what
it is
um and you know because it's better for
the customer and it looks better and the
pictures and all the other stuff and
then we did it and it was great and
everyone agreed it was great at the end
but it was pain to get there
um
those are where those little details are
where the magic comes out right and
you know
if you don't do
if you don't take those pains and put in
the love the customer customer's going
to feel
it's going to they're either going to
feel the pain or they're going to feel
the love
if you put it in right so it depends on
you know
how much time and effort you want to put
into something and what really matters
to you and so how you communicate what
you do
we're human beings after all is there
something you've learned from sort of
the
the tensions that are natural
or that happen in teams when they're
passionate and they're trying to solve
these problems is that the way of life
and there's the human drama
is that just
is that always going is that it is what
it is
is that make you better actually the the
drama of the tension between
personalities and all that kind of stuff
look a roller coaster ride without ups
and downs is no fun
it's the journey yeah it's the journey
that brings it brings out the best in
everyone we're we're
we're forged we're tempered by those
experiences not all the ups but also the
downs and that's when you get the
humanity in the connection and we can
tell these stories till we're blue in
the face and smile every time because we
did something together that we each of
us couldn't do a part but it when your
comes together that's where all the
emotions happen yeah and that's where if
it's born out of the right reasons and
the right story in the right way that's
where the magic happens not just for the
customer but for how it transforms each
person who is working on it and they
will never forget those experiences in
their life
positively and negatively that happened
at the time but they look back and it's
only positive
because they did something that mattered
yet another brilliant idea that you
brought to life is nest
nest thermostat and the big umbrella of
nest
again as part of this uh netflix series
season three
[Laughter]
what was the most memorable the most
painful
the most
um
insight-leading challenge you had to
overcome to bring nest to life
well
the first thing for me
was making someone care about their
thermostat
right no one considers it they never had
any customer choice
they didn't install it they usually
don't even use it because it's so
complicated or what have you they just
like they just they [ __ ] at it they
hide it in the corner
and then they just pay the bill right of
whatever it is right it's totally
unloved unconsidered right so how do you
wake up like i said the virus of doubt
how do you wake that up and get people
going
you know remember every day when you go
in and it's like you're just frustrated
and then you get the bill and you pay
the bill so you have to do that so that
was one thing i think the other big one
was not delivering you know it was all
of it was hard right it was constrained
we had only so much stuff we were
bootstrapped we didn't have massive
funding we didn't get hundreds of
millions of dollars it was but we did it
for the right reasons but i think the
other big part of it was
not just building a disruptive product
because a lot of the people on the team
had done that we knew what we were doing
and and that was
if we got the design right we could
deliver it
with the
enough time
it was getting the disruptive go to
market in other words how to take that
product from the end of the production
line and get it into the customer's
hands
because there was no
retail or customer choice in thermostats
no one even it was never considered
purchase
they never thought they had choice
some guy usually in suspenders and a
butt crack
told them looked around looked at their
house and said um this looks like
somebody who's got is well to do
this thermostat is now going to cost you
350 thank you very much
and you're like i'll take whatever you
give me right and then and it goes into
another house it's worth a hundred
dollars was the same damn thing yeah
right so there's no price transparency
there was no choice you just got what
you were given
so how do you go
and and and this was an entrenched
industry that's why there was no in it
there was no innovation in it because it
was doing just fine because every house
needed them
the
all the installers were programmed by
the the product deliverers by you know
bonuses
and and and bonuses to say you're going
to only carry out product and if you
sell this many you're going to get a
free trip to hawaii
right yeah and for these guys who
install i get a free trip to hawaii
that's dream for them right so
this whole channel was fully controlled
by the product guys and it was almost
monopolistic in a way
so how do you go around that
so
creating a disruptive go to market
channel
one was direct to consumer right and all
the marketing that was necessary to get
that message across
another one was getting the installation
right
no one was self-installing thermostats
so how do we get enough people who are
early adopters to be able to
self-install them confidently
so they didn't still have to call the
guy to come and install it because then
he would say this is a crap product no i
got the must better product right so you
had to get rid of that friction
and then ultimately how do you get the
people who were not just early adopters
but people who needed to see it and
touch it before they bought it how do
you get that into retail when
the large brands of the time of
thermostats and home depot and lowe's
had contracts that they couldn't bring
in any other brands
they were owning the channel all the way
to where there was an any sort of slight
customer choice and it was really
contractor choice more than it was and
consumer choice so all of that had to be
innovated along with the product and so
to me that was a huge challenge and
something i had never done most of us
had never done and we had to
to create that was as much as a project
as actually delivering the the product
itself
so it turned out to be a giant hit
[Laughter]
and it was acquired by google for 3.2
billion dollars
as a founder and leader just out of
curiosity in these cases of acquisition
um
is it always a good thing
is there any part of
you and the team that considers saying
no oh we considered saying no all the
way along the process
right we had all been in big companies
before
um we knew what it was like
and the politics and all the other stuff
and what i came to learn
especially
from phillips because phillips was a
very it was 375 000 people was a big it
was massive company right and tons of
politics and i was like do we want to go
back into the world because i had so
many negative experiences from that
but then going to apple which was no not
big but it was big enough that it could
have all these dynamics but then when
you saw a leader rise up and get rid of
those dynamics or not allow many of them
to to flourish
then you're like oh with the right
leadership this can be a beautiful
marriage right and so for four months we
were working together with them with
google
to make sure that we had the right
leadership and we were going to be in
the right environment that it felt right
so that happened it absolutely happened
we worked on all the details we didn't
even talk about price
we were talking about
how's the brand going to work who's the
team going to work with how are we going
to get ip how are we going to do
exchanges how are we going to get
budgets and all that stuff done so we
worked through all of that before we
actually sealed any kind of deal because
they were already an investor in the
company so we already knew you know they
knew relatively where their you know the
end point was for the price
so working through all those
prerequisites
i knew that
as a individual product company that was
trying to create a platform
no investors were going to invest in a
platform that could take three four
years and many many hundreds of millions
of dollars to build without all kinds of
new products at the same time
and products that we were having which
were successes but they weren't even
break even yet right we were still
developing them so how are we going to
get more people to fund all of these
things and this platform that i really
want to create
because my worry and i had seen this
many times in silicon valley is these
small startups have bravado and they
said i'm going to take on the big guys
right
with a platform
but when those platform guys show up and
apple says they're going to get in the
house at the time nobody cared
they were they were curiously
curious what's nest yeah yeah but apple
wasn't in the market google wasn't in
the market yet amazon wasn't there
microsoft samsung they were not they
were all just that's curious
right
yeah and i had watched if you said i'm
going to go challenge them
and i'm going to build a platform and
then they all of a sudden one by one go
oh well we're building a platform now
we're building a player they flooded you
to death fear uncertainty doubt and the
developers run away and you can't make
that platform so i'm like before the
landscape gets changed on us because
we've attracted so much attention they
announced something we need to change
the landscape
on them
[Music]
let's go to the best place where we can
build out the platform have the right
leadership behind us
to help us grow this thing into what the
vision it should be and that's what we
believe we were doing with the the
google acquisition
is it
possible to take on the platforms so you
said there's a lot of startups with
bravado and all that kind of stuff right
doesn't mean you know james joyce when
he was 20 said i'm going to be the
greatest writer of the 20th century
uh before he wrote anything of value um
you know one of them might be actually
right
[Laughter]
um yeah in this modern world when you so
first of all people should definitely
uh get your book billed as just just uh
this
giant number of advice on this exact
question of how to build
cool things how to build a startup how
to all the different stages of that team
and hiring and it's mostly human nature
it's not technical it's mostly human
nature behind it and it turns out it's
you know turtles all the way down that's
human at the bottom uh
yes so
is it possible
to build startups that take on the big
guys
uh whatever that is of of the modern era
so for now it's these platforms of uh
apple google twitter i don't even know
meta i guess called now sure um is it
possible to take them on absolutely
but you don't take them on on their same
turf
you take them on on the turf they're
gonna want to have in the future
right
spotify is a platform it started as an
application is now a platform yeah right
think of wechat
think of all the super apps out there
that are now wallets and delivery
services and travel services and and
transportation services all within an
app yeah they've innovated in a
different level in a different space
that the the platform companies weren't
right or they you know google was an app
it was an app company it was solving
search
and then it became a platform company
apple was solving personal computing and
then it became our iphone was doing you
know uh
um
solving internet browsing all that stuff
and then became a platform company when
the app store was added if you look it
up
there's no such thing as building a
platform company you build a great app
first and then you can expand it and
have the right to become a platform
your whole book is just
uh a bunch of advice for young people
but let me ask you i know other people
and old well everyone is young at heart
if you're not you should be so what uh
in terms of picking a career you have
advice and this point
what advice would you give to a person
on how to pick a career
what is it you want to learn
and who is it you want to learn from
just like you pick a university
you're like i want to go here for this
expertise i've heard about these
programs especially graduate
graduate studies you go for a certain
program with a certain set of people why
don't you do that when it comes to a
you know
a job you just don't go or in a career
you just don't go and say i just want to
go work at google or i just want to work
at apple you want to go to a certain
team with a certain set of people and
work with them on something that you're
really curious about and you want to
learn about that's such i just wanted to
comment that it's such a
it's a subtle but a brilliant framing of
just ask the question
what do i want to learn and then see
what career path is going to maximize
that
that's so interesting it's the first
question i ask anyone who interviews
with me
when i say i'm going to bring somebody
on the team first question is what do
you want to learn
i don't want the expert like we talked
about earlier says i'm the expert in
this you're going to hire me as the
expert
we're doing something new
you're not an expert because we're not
an expert either what is it you want to
learn
and uh
on the topic of learning
what is the best way to learn
what
um starting you you go into this new
place into this new world
into maybe v1 you said you're building
v1 i mean
the whole world is late
it's full of v1s or v0s waiting for the
v1 to come along zero to one zero to one
what uh what's the process of that look
like what's the process of learning
um how do you learn
well let me put a framing and then we'll
talk about that last piece
i have now looking back especially
writing this book
i have a version one of myself a version
two a version three a version four
i had a lot of opinions
about myself and what i wanted to do
sometimes those opinions for certain
people those opinions are formed
and they get the data from their parents
and they go do what their parents told
them to do or their surroundings
my opinions was like i want to go and
learn this i'm curious about that i made
the zero to one move and then over time
by doing
i was refining those things and learning
what i was really curious about and what
i was really good about because i was
getting data
and then i was like then i had another
set of opinions to create version two of
me
and then i would go and do it it's
always learning by doing
starting with the opinion you're not
gonna get any facts you know most people
like um where do i make the most money
from my position
they're trying to start with data
start with the why
what's your curiosity what do you want
to learn
and then follow that
i took the lowest job at the on the
totem pole at you know at uh at general
magic because i wanted to get in there
to work with the right team i didn't
even know what they were doing
right but i thought that it felt right
right
i i was barely living above the poverty
line working there working you know 80
hours a week because it was so amazing
to learn just like a college student
right that's what i was doing
and then that set and then i learned
more from that and then changed those
opinions into data and then i found
other opinions and so it's the same
thing
but it was by doing
right the way you find out what you want
to do in life is by figuring out what
you don't want to do
and the only way you find that out is by
doing a bunch of doing a bunch of stuff
and refining it that's hilarious yeah
that's brilliant um so in terms of the
career path of leaping into the startup
world and launching a startup
what does it take to successfully found
a startup
to have a chance to succeed
and maybe
how
do you decide
uh to take that leap
is there sort of
having founded having been
part of many v1s many of some of the
most successful v1s ever
uh what's what's it take to take that
leap maybe leave your
job
at a cushy job at a company right and do
the startup what does it take
it takes belief in yourself
that's the first thing
belief that you can do it not but
hopefully with mirrors or mentors around
your coaches around you to make sure you
know you're not crazy
it's a crazy smart idea but you're not
crazy and you're just
working on something as a like a a lone
mad man or woman you know
you have a great idea and i like i said
great ideas chase you
you can
in this world
there are so many people who have more
ideas than they have time to implement
i used to be like that i would like oh
my god have this idea this idea and you
do you try to do all of them
but the best ideas are the ones that you
can really focus on and you you shut out
all those other things and you bring
them other ideas into the thing you're
trying to do so i try to run away from a
great idea
and then it stalks me yeah it hunts you
down because you're like ah that's gonna
have this problem i'm gonna put it aside
and then all of a sudden
uh you know a few days later oh i think
i know how to solve that problem or i
talk to somebody and you're just always
kind of
niggling around the edges of it and then
at some point it's like it just becomes
it becomes like this black hole that
just sucks you and you're like i can't
think about anything else but this it's
almost like a relationship in in the
world right
you know when you have it with a per you
find your partner
you know you're like hmm
wait um something and then you're trying
to like and then all of a sudden it just
it comes together right it's kind of
like that ultimately achieve folk see
i'm different i just dive right in i
used to do that too i used to dive right
in yeah but i learned that you need more
time to run away from it run away from
it and so it chases you because it makes
you think harder about that the story
this is not dating advice we're talking
about
but ultimately so you have achieved uh a
focus on it
uh but you also said so believe in
yourself so it's not necessarily even
the idea it's the human
that
um believe in the human being you have
to believe in you yourself and the idea
that you have because if you don't have
that belief
then you can't project that to other
people to say join the team
[Music]
uh let me
let me ask you on because you mentioned
mentors and you've talked about having
had incredible mentors in your life
you're also a mentor to a very large
number of people what does it take to
find a mentor how do you how do you find
a great mentor usually they also find
you
is it like with the ideas
[Laughter]
no what happens is you're in the right
you have a community around you okay and
because you've been building a network
because you can't do it alone so you
have to create this network around you
and of relationships that don't it's not
transactions but relationships over time
that you really cherish and people you
talk to okay and you share
vulnerable or
nascent ideas with or crazy opinions
with and then you argue them through
but
you start to see resonate and it's not
about age it's just about this
connection right i have mentors
obviously when i was young all my
mentors were older and as i get older i
have mentors who are younger than me or
the same age right they're not all just
older right and so it's about that
connection it's about being on that same
wavelength
but they also they can
counterbalance you
they complement you in some way like my
best mentors had nothing to do with
technology they didn't know anything
about technology
right the way we know it they were all
about human nature and they could
reflect that and help me get more human
focused and more empathetic because i
was so
detailed in the technology i needed to
see from other perspectives but then
they wanted to learn more about the
technology right or they thought that
this idea was so great that it should
exist now let's work together on that
so it's really they have to find you and
you have to find them and that's by
sharing you just don't go and look it up
on
you know on the internet and say who are
the best mentors in the world it just
doesn't work that way
so form a network of people and see
where i mean it's like finding
relationships finding love all that kind
of human nature
uh
venture capitalists money
do vcs help or hurt a business
in general so like in those early stages
in the chase of developing a v1 just
what's the
constructive and destructive
power of money
in the development of a berlin idea
and the deployment of brilliant idea
i have seen brilliant venture
capitalists i have seen horrible ones
ones that care about their lps more than
they care about the entrepreneurs
of course everyone's in it you know at
the end of the day especially venture
capital they have to give a return to
their their limited partners the people
who invest in money that they you know
that they have to shepherd that money
and make sure it's watched over properly
but when there's not a balance a push
back in a venture capitals between what
the lp needs and what the entrepreneur
needs
and that the entrepreneur might be
trying really hard but if they don't see
the vc doesn't see the exit's going to
happen in two years and then just leave
them hanging when it's there's no the
value exchange is only money and not
mentorship or ideas or other things
when there's not a relationship but
really a transaction
that's when money is toxic
because you can get money everywhere
maybe it's a little harder today you
know over the last month
but you can still find people with money
who are on that who want to
enable your mission and can be mentors
not always not all of them but some of
them can be mentors but they they're on
your side
then it's incredibly powerful because
not just one plus one equals two right
it's something bigger than that because
then they can bring their networks of
people and their networks of companies
and other people they worked with that
might want to join your your your
mission right
that's the kind of venture capitalist
and and smart money that's out there
right but you have to build a
relationship people go oh look at that
valuation oh it's the brand name of the
vc that uh that's investing me no
it boils down to who's that partner and
how experienced are they don't just give
me the brand give me the person because
that's the person i'm going to be
interacting with i i have to there's a
million questions i want to ask you bro
well season season we're on season five
already okay but let me let me ask you
it's it seems like
uh out of all the brilliant things you
write about it seems like not an
important question but it's a
fascinating one to me as lawyers
you're right about this so uh does the
company need lawyers
uh and why
and what kind so you write about sort of
the value of this game i guess right
it's a game the legal game
it's it's
why do we need lawyers sound exasperated
i don't have a good question i guess i
um
well because why of lawyers
the why of lawyers yes exactly okay the
y of lawyers
thank you
you even do the question
we just have to put y in front of
everything you ask and then we'll be
there lawyers why why even mafiosos had
lawyers
okay
you know tony soprano uh you know uh
scarface all of them had lawyers right
why
because there are things in this world
that you don't always consider
in the government in laws
in
uh competitors
because you're so focused on what you're
doing they have to watch out for you
right
now the best kind of lawyers are the
ones who try to work with you to enable
what you're doing
um and
see gray areas
law is not black or white it's how it's
interpreted right and so they can help
interpret things a certain way or help
push on things a certain way
to get change happen or allow change to
happen because if you have lawyers who
are always just like you were talking
about pr people
if you have lawyers who are always
saying no to everything because their
job is to really say no or maybe they'll
never say yes
and you also say their job was to say no
and bill you by the hour exactly exactly
it's depressing right
yeah if you don't want to know don't ask
them because you're going to get a no
maybe a man you'll get charged for it
and you'll get charged for it anyways
right
so so to have a partner to have them on
your team to help you see maybe some of
things you don't see some consequences
they help to rein that in or change your
their language like are you going to get
sued for this ad yeah just change this
one word and it helps yeah right
so you need to have a partner most of
the times especially engineers or
designers they see lawyers as only
stifling
lawyers can actually if you do it right
and you have the right type they can
actually open up a whole new world for
you because of the interpretation and
how we go about doing things
so and they help you not get bogged down
in the pain of stupid little mistakes
that didn't mean anything exactly you
shot yourself in the foot and you didn't
even know it you didn't even know you
were carrying the gun
uh just to jump around
charles bukowski once wrote find what
you love and let it kill you
so the question is about work-life
balance
that's like finding an idea let it chase
you
yes but a little more aggressive
uh so
what is uh what does work-life balance
look like that maximizes success and and
or happiness
is there such a thing as work-life
balance is um can you speak
went to this your work is your life and
i mean that in the positive sense
when you're on a mission that really
matters
and you know that you can
really affect not just yourself but
other people's lives and then that is
very rewarding
right
that's not j that's not work that's like
i said a mission right you you adopt
that
but that said you still need to have
boundaries yourself at general magic
wonderful documentary if no one's seen
it you got to see that it's amazing i
was physically and mentally unhealthy
socially and healthy as well because i
put every waking minute into this thing
every ounce of me into it
and when it was a spectacular disaster
we were making the iphone 15 years too
early
the bottom fell out i had nothing left i
had to get
healthy socially emotionally physically
after that
that that trauma
i let everything go i learned from that
that you have to even though you might
put everything into your work you need
to find balance outside of it now that
doesn't mean you're always you know
it's three days a week working and four
days a week or whatever it was you're
still working as hard as ever but what
you're doing is you're making sure when
your thinking time is during work
that you're not ruminating at three in
the morning you use the tools that you
have to put those ideas into databases
or on pages or somewhere else so you can
go back and look at them
so you're not always having to remember
because what happens is most people
don't write the stuff down so they just
sit here and got to remember this i got
to remember this i got to remember this
if you just put it into the tools and
you can come back to it you can come
back fresh yeah a lot of the time is
about ruminating about what i need to
get done and remembering everything
instead of doing the work
that's fascinating see if you just put
it down on paper you can you can
actually escape it right escape it for a
time to have peace for time you
mentioned um
uh general magic
let me ask you
the russian question
uh
what's the uh what's been the uh
the darkest moments of your
of your life what are some of the
darkest places you've gone in your mind
you've talked about you know if you're
doing these kinds of things with
startups you're gonna have to face a
crisis right absolutely if you're doing
it right you're gonna face it so for you
personally
where were some of the tough
tougher moments in your life
growing up
i went to 12 schools in 15 years
i was always the new kid
put yourself in those shoes right
were you picked on well absolutely but
even more so i was the geek with the
computer
remember the nerds in the 80s you you
probably don't know this but believe me
we were made fun of
what were these computers what were
these things you're off in a cold
they're all off partying or going
whatever it was and i'm sitting there
like
they're like this guy is just this alien
right who's this new guy who just showed
up and
and then you know you would ask the
smart questions and you couldn't be the
smartest in the
because then you get picked on too so
and you're the new kid so you're in this
environment that's ever-changing you
don't fit in
and you are just asking questions
because you think they're the right egg
questions to answer but then they like
you're making us look bad don't ask
these smart questions because you make
us do more work
so right there
it's pretty tough and i'm moving cities
right and i didn't have the internet to
stay connected to people there was no
internet
phone calls were two dollars a minute so
it was lonely too it was lonely right
right i was a latchkey kid
right i had my brother but he was a
skateboarder and he had he had a
different social
way of working he he loved to do that
stuff and be outside i loved the
computer so even in the computer you
were alone in the family
with the computer yeah i was in my
family i was absolutely alone that was
just me but then
um then you could find the other geeks
right but there were just a few of us
and we made this little thing but then
when you moved away you know then then i
had to use a bbs
and a bulletin board system and a dial
up modem and then then i started hacking
the phone system to get free codes of
mci and sprint
back in the day to get long distance to
get free coats to call my friends the
geeks on the other side right or to dial
into a bbs cheaply that was in another
part of the world
so
this was this subculture and that was
not accepted in any way and not the
heroes that you see today that are on
the you know on you know the richest
people in the world and everything
so so that was the first set of trauma
and then the next one really was general
magic you know the end of that like i
described before and pulling yourself
out and going just because i got so
insular in that world of geeking out and
and building stuff that i just tore all
the social ties right
because it was just it was a drug i was
hooked on that i was a junkie
i had to get i had to get clean
yeah
and uh
that made
that made you who you are
tempered
um
so
steve jobs is no longer with us
one day you also will no longer be with
us
that's the the
the thing about this life it ends yeah
um
so no matter how many incredible things
you brought to this world no matter how
many inventions you built
you too shall perish do you think about
this
are you afraid of your death
i am not afraid of my death
i am an atheist
and i think about the soul
because i do even though i'm an atheist
i think about the soul and the soul is
the thing that you
instill in others when you go that lives
on
it's not this thing that's magically in
space
it's the thing that you've imparted onto
people that you worked with and those
relationships you've had
and that soul lives on in the stories
that they tell
right
and through build i'm hopeful that those
stories stay relevant because they're
human nature they're not about who knows
what the next iphone thing is or the
next ipod thing is the stuff that i
have been able the privilege to make and
work with people those are all ephemeral
the ipod's gone now right this week it
was announced ipod's dead and after
it is that
those human connections
it's that growth that you've helped
someone just like they helped me
just like bill campbell or steve jobs is
gone but they made me be better that's
the soul that i believe in
that's fascinating that you say that
yeah so
all many of these products i mean to
push back a little bit so even though
the ipod is an end of an era
using it every day
you see i i think that i mean the number
of people that impacted
is it's just
uh so i i suppose the soul is carried by
the people exactly sometimes the
products you create as the sort of the
transport mechanism
it's the vessel
and they felt the love and they felt
that love and it transformed it even if
they don't have the vessel anymore yeah
and that way the soul lives just like
the body is the vessel that's
beautifully put
why do you think we're here
what's the meaning of life tony
jesus
we're going all around me of life why
why because you said it's important to
have a press release
okay humanity if life on earth if if
this thing the consciousness the
falling in love and building bridges and
ipods
and rockets and trying to extend out
into the cosmos why
why do you think we're doing it
is there anything
we are naturally curious
where we are naturally curious
individuals
and
we are always looking for
meaning
we're always trying to ascribe meaning
to something or or understanding of
something
right and through that it's just just
like evolution right and darwinism it's
just that thing that's baked into our
being at the most fundamental level
driven by curiosity driven by curiosity
and creating some pretty cool things
along the way tony you you and speaking
of cool things you've created some of
the coolest things
ever
and on top of that you're just an
amazing human being it's a huge honor
that you'll sit and talk to me today
this is a fun
lex this is this is great i did i didn't
know where it was going and i'm
let's talk i've been looking for seats i
would love seven eight nine six seven
yes let's go hang out and and have
dinner and just rap about all kinds of
crates i'd love to continue this i would
too thank you so much thank you
thanks for listening to this
conversation with tony fidel to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description
and now let me leave you with some words
from tony fidel himself
the most wonderful part of building
something together with a team
is that you're walking side by side with
other people
you're all looking at your feet and
scanning the horizon at the same time
some people will see things you can't
and you will see things that are
invisible to everyone else
so don't think doing the work just means
locking yourself into a room a huge part
of it is walking with your team
the work is reaching your destination
together
or finding a new destination and
bringing the team with you
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time
you